Most heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes, from long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
KappaPogChamp, keep a forehead, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
I remember typing Dan's game, forehead, SwiftRage, PJ Salt and FailFish.
Life was easy, spamming all the time.
Excellent. Wieso? 9.10 Uhr? Äh, plötzlich. Komme ich auf 9.10 Uhr. Vollkommen normaler Streamzeit am Sonntag.
Ist heute Sonntag? Ja. Soll ich euch mal was sagen? In genau 1, 2, 2,5 Wochen habe ich Urlaub und zwar eine Woche.
Also die restliche Woche davon, 1 Woche, 2 Wochen, 3 Wochen, 4 Wochen, 5 Wochen, 6 Wochen, 7 Wochen.
Excellent. 3 Monate, 12 Monate? Dankeschön. Du hast es geschafft, du bist jetzt offiziell.
Z-Pudding neu, oder? Danke schön für den Sub. Twitch emotes. Ach ja.
Wupp, wupp, wupp. Los gucken, dass es jetzt bis zu laut ist, weil diese Streams dazu neigen, schlecht abgemixed zu sein und nicht zu wissen, ob sie laut oder leise sein wollen.
Ja, die können sich wieder nicht entscheiden, das ist Wahnsinn.
Jetzt ist es wieder. Ich glaube, so geht es.
So, genau. Also wie gesagt, 7 Wochen Urlaub, das ist excellent. Und wisst ihr was, je nachdem, wie man es sieht, für die meisten ist das nicht so excellent.
Es ist jetzt ja kein Lockdown offiziell, es ist ja nur ein Slowdown. Das ist auch die geilste Umschreibung aller Zeiten, leider.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen, das ist ganz verdrängt.
Ja, aber uns so als Hacker-Mans ist uns das eh egal, denn wir sitzen eh den ganzen Tag voll rechner unten im Keller mit Hoodie auf, wie man ja weiß.
Wer braucht Sonne und Kontakt mit echten Leuten? Deswegen sage ich ja Gamer Master Race, was Corona Lockdown angeht.
Für uns ist das absolut nichts Besonderes.
Was hast du denn im Urlaub vor? Nix? Sorry, falsches E-Mode.
Nix habe ich vor, was willst du machen?
Früher bin ich ab und an mal um die Zeit nach Dresden zum Frasier und zum Mastercrubber gefahren, also auch nicht oft, aber ab und zu mal, aber das fällt jetzt ja auch flach.
Also die Möglichkeit fällt flach, sondern mit wem soll ich mich sonst treffen?
Ich habe doch keine Freunde, wisst ihr doch.
Zumindest keine Leute, mit denen ich mich treffen will.
Ich habe vielleicht eine Handvoll Leute, die mir nicht auf den Sack gehen.
Das war's.
Die restlichen Leute will ich gar nicht sehen.
Ich kann auch nicht mal mit dem Kabum irgendwie Sushi fuddern gehen oder so jetzt.
Exquisite.
Ich habe den Chat, genau, genau.
Ähm, tja.
Aber ich wette mit euch, das bleibt eh nicht bei November.
Wir haben ja gesagt,
ja, die Lautstärke von diesem komischen Stream kann ich echt nicht entscheiden.
Die haben ja gesagt, so nach dem Motto, ja, das ist jetzt ganz kontrolliert und alle zwei Wochen setzen sich zusammen und es ist nur beschränkt auf November.
Das halte ich ja persönlich für totalen Blödsinn.
Es will einfach keiner sagen, was ist.
Gibt es zu Silvester eigentlich wieder Null-Uhr-Stream?
Das kann durchaus sein, ja, das ist eine gute Idee, wahrscheinlich machen wir das sogar.
Vielleicht machen wir wieder Silvester-Stream.
Ja, aber das ist total, total, totaler Schwachsinn.
Ähm, die sagen einfach nur November, weil die Leute sich sonst aufregen würden.
Also es regen sich ja jetzt schon, es regen sich ja jetzt schon genug Leute auf über die ganze Geschichte.
Wenn die gesagt hätten, so wie es realistisch ist, wir machen das so lange, bis es die Zahlen erlauben, dass es wieder besser wird, ja,
dann wären die alle komplett, komplett eskaliert, ja.
Die hätten alle das hier gemacht, die hätten Face-Rolled den ganzen Tag über die Tastatur und hätten auf Twitter sich ausgekotzt.
Machen sie ja jetzt auch schon.
Ist ja nichts Neues.
Komm, wir gucken heute mal eine Runde Battlefield am Anfang.
Irgendwo habe ich doch ein Battlefield-Video.
Exzellent, ey.
Ob ich's denn...
Da.
Exquisite.
Das ist ein 14 Jahre altes Oto-Video einfach vorgeschlagen.
Ja, warum nicht?
Scam.
Ah ja.
Evolution of Windows-Error-Sounds, okay.
Ah, yes, hat sich ja viel geändert.
Oh nee, kennt das noch...
Leute, das kennen plus, das kennen plus Leute, die, keine Ahnung, in den 80er geboren sind,
wie ich. 84 bin ich geboren. Diesen Kram kennt sonst keiner mehr. Also, das hier kenne ich auch nicht mehr, das war noch vor meiner Zeit.
Aber das hier, aber das hier.
Pass mal auf, das hier.
Tümp.
Moment, es gab kein Windows NT 5.
Das ist ein Windows NT 5.
Das gab kein Windows NT 5.
Gab gar kein Windows NT 5. NT 5 war NT 5 nicht, 2000?
Neptune, Neptune gab's doch auch nicht. Neptune war auch ein Codename für irgendwie.
Ähm, heute, heute macht's...
Blubblubblub. So, so ungefähr, so ein bisschen wie das hier macht's heute.
Oh.
Das war ja...
Wusste gar nicht, dass die für Windows...
Das war ja der Vista Codename.
Dass die so einen komischen Sound dafür hatten.
Hab ich denn nie gehört.
Oh.
Excellent.
Advanced Error Message.
Also besser wird's eigentlich auch nicht, oder?
Genau. Ich sag doch, jetzt macht's so.
So ähnlich, so ähnlich wie das hier.
Tüttüttüm.
Hab, Moment, jetzt wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Hat mein Windows eigentlich schon das letzte Update?
Ich hab immer noch 20.04. Warum?
Ich hatte den letzten Stream schon 20.04.
Oh, Shutdown Sounds.
Auch ex, exquisite.
Das letzte Mal schon. Update.
Krieg ich jetzt das neue Update?
Check Update.
Irgendwie krieg ich das nicht.
Alle, alle haben's schon. Ich mein, nicht, dass man das möglich bräuchte.
20H2.
20H2 kommt eh nix interessantes.
Äh, Windows Defender.
Who cares?
Tja, nö, nö.
Ich krieg, ich krieg kein 20H2.
Gibt's nicht.
War doch da, wo?
Wo war das?
Debated?
Was, wie, wo war das?
Bekommst du das überhaupt, wenn du in der 20.04 Version...
Ist ja klar, 20.04 ist der Vorgänger von 20H2.
Das ist nur Microsoft-Benamung, die man nicht versteht.
Also, wer würde nicht...
Äh, wer würde nicht vermuten,
dass der Vorgänger von 20H2
20.04 ist?
Oder der Nachfolger von 20.04 20H2?
Das ist doch vollkommen logisch.
Also, ich weiß wirklich nicht,
wie man auf irgendwelche anderen Ideen kommen kann.
So.
Echt, stand das irgendwo da, Leute?
Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Wo, wo stand hier grad H2?
Ihr habt debated mich.
Chat, Chat.
Ihr debated mich.
Aber ihr vergesst, dass ich nachgucken kann.
Dass ich nachgucken kann.
Dass ich nachgucken kann,
ob ihr mich debated oder nicht.
Debater exposed.
Machen wir jetzt. Also.
Erstmal Sound ausmachen.
So, wo ist es denn? Hier.
He doesn't know.
Genau. Oh, es ist denn nix hier.
So, also hier. So, hier fang ich jetzt an.
Wo steht der H2?
Was können wir das später anschauen?
Corona,
Tollhaus Berlin, Reportage aus dem...
Was für ein Ding.
Och nee.
Ja, du hast da schon ein paar merkwürdige
Leute, aber...
Nee, das gucken wir uns nicht an.
So, also wo steht da was von H2?
So, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt müsst ihr gleich kommen.
Nix steht... Oh!
Oh, da steht da wirklich was.
Warum ist das jetzt weg?
Ach nee, jetzt ist es mit... Nee.
Das ist es, oder?
2020 10.
Was 2020 H2? Das ist es doch hier.
Da ist es doch wieder.
Das ist das... Das ist das Gleiche, oder?
Das ist... Warum kann man das Fernseher...
Das ist das... Das ist das Gleiche.
Das mache ich jetzt nicht, sonst muss ich neu starten.
Das mache ich jetzt nicht, ich reboote jetzt nicht.
Warum haben wir das jetzt?
Warum heißt denn das einmal so und bei dem anderen...
Was auch immer, ich mach das später.
Excellent Windows Aerosounds Brommel.
Muss ich mir jetzt noch mal kurz geben.
Ah, jetzt Shutdown Sounds.
Exquisite Shutdown Sounds.
Excellent.
Der Chat IQ ist schon wieder...
Das ist jenseits von Sixhead schon wieder.
So, kurz hochscrollen, ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe.
Kein Chat übersehen.
Hab ich euch... Set Pudding.
Dankeschön für den Sub, ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon gesehen habe.
Ich habe jetzt übrigens RGB-Lichter in meinem Smart Home eingebunden.
Ich habe jetzt angefangen, auch mit Lichtautomatisierung.
Wurde langsam Zeit.
Weil mein Fernseher hat nur 60Hz.
Und ich hoffe mit RGB wird das ein bisschen flüssiger alles.
Das war... Da kann ich mich schon dran erinnern.
Und damals hatten wir...
Damals waren wir ja noch richtig Low-Brain.
Und ich habe unter Windows 95 immer die...
Warum will ich das jetzt eigentlich auf 1080p stellen?
Das macht hier keinen Unterschied.
Ich habe damals immer Custom Sounds gemacht.
Fürs runterfahren.
Damals fand man es so geil, dass man so...
Am Rechner auch Sound aufnehmen konnte und so was.
Und dann gab es diesen Windows Audio Recorder...
Oh, den gibt es immer noch.
Audio Recorder?
Nein.
Darfst du nicht.
Piss dich, Alde.
Ähm...
Moment.
Windows 95 Audio Recorder.
Das war die schlechteste Aufnahmesoftware aller Zeiten.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ja, so sah das aus.
So sah das aus in Windows 95, das Ding.
Guck es euch mal an.
Exzellent Aufnahmeprogramm.
Und da habe ich dann mit ein paar Leuten aus der Schule manchmal da gesessen und wir haben...
Windows Sound Files aufgenommen.
So richtig blöd.
Und wir haben dann so einen...
So einen Shutdown Sound aufgenommen.
Der war irgendwie...
So Selbstzerstörung in C9.
Ach, so richtig dumm, was man halt gemacht hat in dem Alter, ja.
Und der war irgendwie 30 Sekunden lang.
Und ich fand diesen Shutdown Sound so geil,
dass ich mir den eingestellt habe.
Und das Problem war, ich war dann immer zu ungeduldig,
den Shutdown Sound abzuwarten und habe meinen Rechner immer ausgeschaltet.
Und ihr...
Vielleicht erinnert sich der ein oder andere...
Also eigentlich richtig low-brainer.
Erst mal einen Shutdown Sound einstellen, den man geil findet,
aber dann will man sich den Shutdown Sound nicht jedes Mal anhören
und schaltet den Rechner einfach aus.
Zumindest, wozu das geführt hat, war,
dass das Filesystem auf meinem Windows
alle paar Wochen defekt war,
weil ich ungünstig ausgeschaltet habe.
Und man hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht,
ich würde daraus lernen, habe ich aber nicht.
Ich habe dann Windows neu installiert,
weil ich das Einzige war,
was ich damals konnte, war, gut Windows,
oft Windows neu installieren.
Und dann habe ich wieder so einen
bescheuerten Sound eingestellt.
Ja, aber das war exakt...
Das ist übrigens der Start-Sound.
Und...
Ist glaube ich Shutdown von 95 gewesen.
Oder?
Nee,
das ist glaube ich Windows 7, oder?
Gucken wir mal.
Nee, doch!
Das, genau, 95.
Das klang so futuristisch an.
Windows NT.
Also, das war wirklich ein Ding.
Ich meine, das war zwar
stabiler als 95,98,
aber das lief halt nichts drauf.
Das war so das
Business Big Brain System, in dem
du nichts machen konntest.
Ich weiß noch, damals musste man
Sound-Triber, nee, damals
musste man einen CD-Triber
installieren von Diskette, weil
Windows NT das nicht konnte.
Und von der CD konnte man dann den Triber für die
Soundcard installieren und so was.
Oh, das...
Ist das einfach der gleiche Soundrückwärts abgespielt?
Da waren aber die Microsoft Engineers
haben alles gegeben hier.
What the fuck?
Das hört sich an, als wüsste
von Außerirdischen entführt.
Ja, den kenn ich natürlich
noch.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was Windows 98 Shutdown
war.
Ah, stimmt, stimmt.
Es gab ja auch unter Windows 98, gab's ja
auch so geile Soundpacks und
Theme-Packs und so was.
Also, man geil waren die eigentlich nicht, wenn man mal ehrlich ist.
Die sahen zum größten Teil ziemlich kacke aus.
Hier, Windows 98 Aquarium
und so was gab's dann.
Aquarium Desktop
und solche Dinger
richtig hängen geblieben, eigentlich.
Und es sah auch nicht gut aus,
aber man fand sich irgendwie geil,
wenn man so komische
so komische Dinger hatte
auf Windows 98 Schrechner.
Ja, oh,
der war nice.
Den haben sie doch, haben sie den nicht behalten
bis, haben sie den nicht noch behalten
bis, bis
XP sogar?
Da kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Ach nee, ME war's.
Hatten sie unter XP
nicht auch den gleichen Sound als Welcome Sound?
Das hört sich an, als hat irgendwie einer
die vergangenen Windows-Sounds übereinander gelegt
und einen Sound-File
draus gemacht.
Aber die meinten das ernst
mit Beta-Versionen. Da hat's sogar das Sound-Beta
angehört bei Microsoft.
Ach, das war
Windows XP, genau.
War das nicht das gleiche
wie bei 2000?
Doch, ne?
Nee, nein.
Das war was ganz anderes.
Irgendwie hab ich Eindruck gehabt, das wäre das gleiche,
aber ist es nicht.
Du, du, du, du, genau.
Pains Champ.
Aber für den Stop-Sound
hatten sie keinen.
Was ist das?
Das ist Windows 8, ne?
Nee, warte mal.
Longhorn ist Vista gewesen, Vista.
Aha.
Richtige Hackerman-Sounds.
Oh ja.
Das hatten sie bei Windows 7 dann aber auch noch.
Das hatten sie bei Windows 7 auch noch.
Ja, ja.
Jaja, Windows XP ist 2001.
Man ist schon ganz schön alt.
Keg Windows, genau.
Das hab ich nie gehört,
weil ich hab Windows 8 komplett geskippt.
Ich glaub der Fabian hat bis heute noch Windows 8
auf seinem Rechner, könntest du dir mal vorstellen.
Und jetzt Windows 10.
Das kennen wir alle.
Was?
Ernsthaft?
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Ja, das kenn ich.
Ich hab den Start-up-Sound von Windows 10 noch nie gehört,
ehrlich gesagt.
Habt ihr den schon mal gehört?
Das war mir jetzt komplett neu.
Das hat keiner gehört.
Fake News.
Es gab mal so ein cooles Video von ein paar Jahren,
da hat einer geupgraded von
Windows 1 auf
bis Windows 7
oder so war das damals.
Oder vielleicht sogar schon Windows 10.
Der hat durchupgraded von 1 auf 10.
Der wollt's echt wissen hier.
Windows 1 bis Windows 10.
Ja.
Der upgraded
komplett durch von
einem System. Oh, Moment, Leute.
Was ist das hier?
Ist das etwa ein
Leak?
Sauerei.
Anzeige ist raus.
Einfach
Sicherheitskopie Windows
95 Keys.
Wenn das mal Microsoft mitkriegt.
Ach nee, auch noch ME war das.
Soll ich euch mal was sagen? Ich fand diesen Installer eigentlich ganz
hübsch damals.
Aber ich glaub, das ist der Nostalgiefaktor,
der
das hält nicht so ganz stand für heute.
Wahrscheinlich war der gar nicht so toll.
Aber ich verbinde da
recht gute
Erinnerungen dran an diesen Windows Installer,
weil das war so zu der Zeit, wo ich
eigentlich beknackt, weil Windows
war nicht wirklich...
Also umso öfter man den Windows Installer sieht,
umso schlechter
ist es ja eigentlich.
Aber
irgendwie
wahrscheinlich hat mir die Zeit gefallen.
Da bist du dann
heimgekommen, hast Half Life 1 gespielt
mit ein paar Leuten und so.
Ja, wahrscheinlich deswegen. Und vielleicht
erinnert sich der eine oder andere noch, wenn man sich damals
getroffen hat und hat
versucht, so ein bisschen Netzwerk,
ein Spiel übers Netzwerk zu spielen. Das war eine entweder
BNC-Kabel
für die Netzwerkkarte.
Solche Dinger hier.
Wenn du da einen Switch hattest,
AJ45-Stecker, warst du
richtig modern.
Und wir haben damals alle gesagt,
wir machen unser Netzwerk
lieber weiter so, weil
wenn du ja einen Switch hast mit
AJ45-Kabel-Stecker,
müsstest du ja von jedem
Rechner
zum Switch einen Kabel legen.
Und so viel Kabel hatten wir damals nicht.
Und das war dann meistens so, dass irgendwie einer
auch unter dem Dach war, zwei Leute,
und dann irgendwie im Erdgeschoss zwei Leute
und mit so einem BNC-Kabel war das kein Problem.
Du hast einfach drei
mega lange BNC-Kabel genommen
und hast beim unteren angefangen
und hast dann quer durchs Haus gelegt
und hast beim oberen aufgehört. Das war ja
so alles an einem Kabel mit
T-Stück
dran. Genau, das Ding hast du
damals an die Netzwerkkarte gemacht. Also jetzt mal ein bisschen
Boomer-Stories wieder, ne?
Das hast du damals an die Netzwerkkarte gemacht.
Hier ging da ein Kabel rein, hier ging das Kabel wieder raus.
So und am Ende
musst du irgendeiner so einen Terminator
dran stecken.
Das ist so ein Ding, das was funktioniert.
Richtig Boomer-Lahn-Party, wobei man ehrlich sagen muss,
Boomer sind ja eigentlich Leute, die so
keine Ahnung, 1960 oder so geboren sind
oder 65 oder 70 oder
frag mich nicht.
Mit 1984 bin ich ja
streng genommen kein Boomer. Ich bin so
hybrid aus Zoomer und
Boomer. Ich weiß nicht,
wie man es richtig
nennen soll.
Das war nicht Token Ring, ne, ne, ne. Das ist
ganz normales Alternat gewesen.
Aber halt über BNC-Kabel
shared medium. Schön
Kollision und Kollisionserkennung
und alle möglichen Sachen. So das, was man
in der Schule lernt, war damals noch relevant.
Jetzt ist
wurscht.
Bileniak bist du... heißt das so?
Wirklich? Das klingt ja
dumm.
Bileniak, Alter.
Okay,
kurz YouTube auf, ob es
etwas sinnvolles vorschlägt.
Makarov ist in
MW1.
Jetzt haben die einfach nur
recht gebogen.
Grating-Counters,
diese Videos finde ich total sinnlos,
weil so eine Map nachbauen in einer anderen
Engine ist das eine. Aber du müsstest ja das komplette
Gameplay nachbauen und das ist auch nicht so ohne.
Ja.
So, was gucken wir? Was können wir gucken? Wir gucken jetzt
erstmal eine Runde Battlefield. Erstmal eine Runde Battlefield-Video.
Das kann man zum Einstieg immer wunderbar gucken.
Exzellent Battlefield-Video.
Kollisionserkennung,
ja, das musste es jemals noch um
alle möglichen... um alle möglichen...
Ach Leute, jetzt wo so viele
Leute... jetzt wo schon viele Leute da sind,
ich habe mal eine Frage an euch.
Gibt es jemand von euch,
der
fünf Sekunden
YouTube-Intro
machen kann?
Und zwar, ansonsten gehe ich zu
Fyber. Aber mir wäre das lieber, wenn das
irgendeiner von euch macht, mit dem man sich dann auch mal
auf Deutsch austauschen kann.
Und nicht unbedingt... muss auch nicht
umsonst sein. Und nicht unbedingt
auf Fyber, wo ich dann wieder bei irgendeinem Inder lande
oder so.
So, fünf Sekunden
YouTube-Intro.
Allerdings, nein nein nein, wir wollen keinen Tetris haben.
Ihr werdet es nicht glauben.
Ich habe jetzt eine Liste
mit an die 20 Videos
für den Dezember.
Ich habe nicht alles
aufgenommen davon.
Aber das Wichtigste bei mir ist erstmal, ich muss wissen,
über was ich rede. Oder
was ich mache.
Da sind alle möglichen Sachen drinne.
24 Videos werden es insgesamt.
Es gibt nämlich ab 1. Dezember, wenn das
alles so hinhaut,
es gibt nämlich ab 1. Dezember, wenn das alles so hinhaut,
jeden Tag ein
Weihnachtskalender-Video.
Und dann mache ich wieder sechs Monate
nichts.
So wird es wahrscheinlich.
Da ist alles Mögliche dabei.
Von
Boomer im Homeoffice als Thema
zu irgendwelchen
Linux-Geschichten,
zu aktuellen, zu allen möglichen Sachen.
Komplett random.
Alle möglichen Sachen, die mir so eingefallen sind,
die interessant sein könnten.
Das kommt mir, Actors,
das kommt mir bekannt vor. Kann sich da noch einer dran
erinnern, wo ich
alle getrollt habe hier?
Hallo, meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren, ich begrüße Sie.
Das ist so cringe, ich kann mir das gar nicht
mehr anhören. Ich kann mir das nicht anhören,
das ist zu cringe. Das ist übelst
fremdschämlich, wenn man scheiß anhören muss.
Von
2011. Und guck mal,
das haben so viele Leute geglaubt
damals. Die waren so
bescheuert. Die waren so
dumm.
336.
Okay, was ist 336?
Teilnehmen.
Ja.
Richtig dummes Video gewesen,
ne?
Aber lustig, ne?
Die meisten
haben es, die meisten haben es
gecheckt.
Ja, die meisten haben es gecheckt. Aber es gibt
auch paar, die haben es wirklich ernst
genommen, dass ich hier
Modern Warfare 3 geflamed habe als
brutales Killer-Game.
Ich hab mich ja dann ausgetauscht mit Christian
Pfeiffer vorher.
Über die aktuellen
Entwicklungen, was Killer-Games angeht und
da ist danach dieses Video entstanden.
Ja.
Oh man.
Den Pfeiffer gibt's immer noch,
ja, tatsächlich.
Den Pfeiffer,
der hat sich letztens wieder geäußert zu irgendwas.
Der hat letztens wieder gesagt,
was hat er erzählt?
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, das ist so irrelevant,
was der Kell sagt.
Nvidia oder AMD-Grafikkarte?
Aktuell tendiere ich noch zu Nvidia.
Was hat der letztens wieder?
Der hat letztens wieder irgendwas
von sich gegeben.
Oh.
Oh nein, wir können uns den Vortrag nicht an.
Das ist ja...
Genau, E-Sport.
E-Sport hat er gesagt. E-Sport
ist schlecht. E-Sport...
Alter, der Typ, der sieht mittlerweile,
der sah ja noch nie sonderlich hübsch aus. Aber mittlerweile
weiß ich nicht, warum, Alter, warum muss man Fotos
von dem Kerl abdrucken? Das ist ja...
Das ist ja Körperverletzung fast schon.
Mittlerweile zieht er
über E-Sports her.
Mittlerweile ist E-Sports
die Einstiegsdroge und ganz,
ganz furchtbar böse.
Der Kerl, der kann's...
Ich mein...
Findet ihr nicht auch, dass so ein Experte
aussieht, der sich gerade im Bereich E-Sports
bestimmt extrem gut
auskennt? Außerdem, warum hat er
ein Pobel in der Nase auf dem Bild? Das ist so...
Geh mal fort.
So, wo ist mein Battlefield-Video?
Wir gucken jetzt Battlefield. Oh.
Warum hab ich noch mal das Bild von meinem Klopapier
offen?
Klimakriesel?
Ach, Klimakriesel.
Ich hab keine Klimakriesel.
Was soll Klimakriesel sein?
Stimmt, ist morgen nicht Wahl in den USA?
Nee, übermorgen. Übermorgen. Ist glaub ich dritter, ne?
Dienstag.
Bin ich froh,
bin ich froh, dass ich
mein Twitter-Land
auf Andorra stehen hab?
Da muss ich mich nämlich mit diesen Trends
hier nicht auseinandersetzen.
Wenn ich diese Trends hier schon wieder seh
auf Twitter Deutschland, dann weiß ich, ich will
den Scheiß gar nicht lesen.
Ach ja, genau. Und zum Thema Intro.
Also vielleicht ist ja jemand von euch dabei, der gut
Intros machen kann.
Ich hätte gerne irgendein weihnachtliches Intro
von 5 Sekunden.
Muss nicht umsonst sein.
Gibt Kohle für.
Aber mir wär's halt lieber,
wenn ich das mit einem von euch machen kann, falls wir
jemanden haben, der sowas gut kann,
als über Pfeiffer mit irgendwelchen
Indern oder so.
Willst du ein Video zu RedStarOS geben? Nee, das ist
ausgelutscht schon.
Also wenn ihr euch da auskennt,
könnt ihr mir einfach im Discord mal schreiben.
Das müssen wir jetzt nicht hier
über den Chat machen.
Ansonsten geh ich zu Pfeiffer.
In welcher Richtung das Intro?
Ja, das ist halt die Sache. Also
ich hab da keine so genau vorgestellt.
Irgendwas weihnachtliches, vielleicht
mit dem Keks, der irgendwie
keine Ahnung, das muss 5 Sekunden
kann man nicht viel machen. Ein bisschen
Weihnachtsaun, Schneeflocken,
keine Ahnung, der Keks unter dem Weihnachtsbaum
bisschen animiert oder so.
Oder vielleicht, dass dann irgendwie noch so ein Buch aufgeht
und irgendwie was da steht.
Irgendwie sowas.
Also bisschen, bisschen
was Weihnachtliches.
Hast du die Juno House mal angeschaut? Ich hab da ein bisschen
was drüber gelesen, ich hab aber keine Ahnung
so genau, was man damit machen kann.
Das ist irgendeine Plattform,
wo man, glaub, so ein Webfront
für Container oder sowas ist das.
Der Keks
fliegt mit dem Schlitten, sowas.
Richtig gute Idee, richtig gute Idee.
Sowas zum Beispiel, der Keks fliegt mit dem Schlitten
über den Bildschirm und dann
kommt irgendwie ein bisschen weihnachtliche Musik
und unten kann ich den Titel einblenden
oder sowas. Nix groß, 5 Sekunden reicht
dicke.
So, alles klar, da gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal
in Battlefield. Exzellent.
Ich mach übrigens, bevor es wieder
werde, ich mach den Typ absichtlich nicht lauter.
Erstens sagt er jedes Mal das Gleiche
und außerdem laber ich eh drüber.
Also diese
Kommentare muss man sich wirklich nicht geben.
Aber die Gameplay ist immer nice.
Kennt das noch jemand?
In der Kiste verstellt.
Das hab ich ja schon wieder komplett vergessen.
Ja, die Kiste so geil.
Ja, ich erinnere mich noch.
Dunkel dran.
Rion, ich hab schon gesehen, der Pfeifer ist am Start.
Ich glaub, das gehts aber nur auf der
Metro Version von Battlefield 3.
Ich bin mir auch gar nicht sicher, ob es das
noch überhaupt gibt in Battlefield 3.
Aber in Battlefield 4 gibt es das auf jeden Fall.
Ich bin mir auch gar nicht sicher, ob es das
noch überhaupt gibt in Battlefield 3.
Aber in Battlefield 4 gibt es das auf jeden Fall nicht mehr.
Die Gegner sind so blöd wieder.
Also man wurde hier wirklich nicht richtig gesehen,
aber man müsste hier mal so halbwegs checken.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Man muss halt sagen, Battlefield 3 war wirklich sehr...
hat einem sehr viel vergeben, was Hitbox und so angeht.
Ich mein, guckt euch das mal an.
Guckt euch das jetzt mal an.
Guckt mal, der trifft...
Der trifft den Typ teilweise gar nicht richtig.
Und er fällt trotzdem um.
Deswegen habe ich so ein verhältnismäßig gutes Aim immer,
wenn ich Battlefield 3 spiele.
Und wenn ich dann spiele, spiele, wo es wirklich drauf ankommt,
dann treffe ich nichts.
Also Battlefield 3 hat ja schon wirklich viel vergeben.
Ist das Hardcore? Die fallen so extrem schnell um.
Und die sind so...
Alter, sind die brain-dead die Gegner?
Ja gut, da hat es zu sehr übertrieben jetzt.
Aber die waren wirklich richtig hängen geblieben.
A short and sweet clip from Scream playing on Damavampic.
M16. Wie sie alle Farbenblind-Modus spielen hier.
Oh.
Aufs Dach? Nein, nicht aufs Dach.
Doch aufs Dach.
Ich glaube, hier gab es gar keine Treppe hoch.
A huge point stack. In Battlefield 3,
you can drop yourself the ammo pack in the support class
and replenish the C4.
A little bit too much time, in my opinion,
but definitely good if you're trying to clear a...
Wie sie reinrennen.
...skipping forward a little bit,
he switches out to his PKP Pecheneg
and starts spraying down enemy players.
It takes a while...
Ich glaube nicht, dass er das Pecheneg ausspricht.
Das ist russisch. Das spricht man bestimmt ganz anders aus.
But then, they eventually do.
Das zeige ich euch heute aber noch auf jeden Fall.
Noch paar Mal.
Hat der...
Ich habe jetzt gesehen,
hat der einen Standaufstellding dabei gehabt,
weil ansonsten wackelt das Ding doch viel mehr
rum über Range, oder?
Oh, weggemessert.
Was man hat gesehen,
wer in deinem Squad war und wer nicht als Medic.
Hä?
Ah, genau. Ah, das war's.
Das war's, okay.
Ich...
Siehst du mal,
ich dachte, man sieht die Nameplates weiter.
Hab ich am Anfang hier gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Zack.
Nose-Hair-Cannons.
Die sind da wirklich wieder bladlos, Alter.
Der Sound war auch so geil.
Zack in the Cop.
Next.
Hallo.
Also wie sie das wieder nicht gebacken bekommen,
ihn zu killen, ist mir absolut...
schleierhaft.
Was mit dem tut?
Oh, jetzt... Ich wollte gerade sagen, also wenn der
den jetzt nicht killt, dann ist wirklich komplett
Pepega-Modus angesagt.
Ja, der da.
Spielst du noch Battlefield 3 ab und zu mal, ja?
Und, äh, also
Battlefield 3 und 4 ist halt das Einzige,
was ich mir geben kann.
Easykiller, 13 Monate.
Massive Subscription.
149.
Wie sie einfach vor...
Ha, wie sie vor ihm gespotzt.
Also, man muss ja sagen, perfekt
war das Game wirklich nicht.
Vor allem im TDM...
im TDM nicht.
Aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, mich
fuckt es deutlich
weniger ab,
in einem Battlefield 3 TDM zu sterben,
als in einem Call of Duty TDM.
Ich kann mir das nicht so genau erklären,
aber ich kann mir das nicht so genau erklären,
warum.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die Tode
meistens daran liegen,
dass ich halt
sinnlos gelaufen bin.
Im Vergleich zu irgendeinem random Call of Duty
Tod, wo dich einer abcampt aus dem Fenster
oder dich random irgendwas across the map
erwischt.
Keg W.
Ja, Trion.
Keg Triple U quasi.
Keg WWW.
Das wäre doch...
Das wäre doch auch mal eine gute Domain, oder?
Oder?
Nee, nee, wobei, das müsste umgedreht sein.
www.kegg.
Gibt es Punkt kegg als Top-Level-Domain?
Gibt es...
Punkt kegg?
www.kegg?
Es gibt keine Top-Level-Domain.
Es gibt keinen Punkt Kegg?
Het gibt kein Point Kegg.
Es gibt keinen Punkt Kegg.
Das ist ja was.
Das... ich dachte,
es gibt mittlerweile so gut wie alles als Top-Level-Domain.
Mh, mh.
Alter, die lassen sich
wieder so krasse wegspringen,
die Gegner.
Und wisst ihr, was ich auch geil finde an dem Devil Masks?
Und wisst ihr was ich auch geil fand in Battlefield 3 und auch in Battlefield 4, wie die rumgeschrien haben, Grenade, Grenade
Oder, oder, da gibt es noch dieses eine Voice Sample, wo der Typ irgendwie rumschreit, I get fucked in the ass
Das, das haben sie sich danach irgendwie nicht mal getrauen
I get fucked in the ass over hier, sagt er noch in Battlefield 3
Ahem, ahem
Did, did, did, did, did
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr was an dem Sound auch geil war?
Das ist jetzt recorded, man letztendlich macht keinen Unterschied, das ist halt linke und rechte Spur
Aber sogar in diesem YouTube Video erkenne ich, wo Gegner sind und wo die her schießen
Sogar in dem YouTube Video, ja?
Und es gibt aktuelle Spiele, da hören sich Schüsse von rechts hinter dir so an, als kämen sie von vorne
Ohne
Ah, jetzt wird er wieder schön geflamet wegen der Shotgun
Mauer einschützen lassen
Ha!
Was mit dem
Was ist mit dem los?
Ja, der war wirklich gut
Ja, der war wirklich planlos
Das ist aber auch Glück, dass das klappt
Sag mal, die trefft ja gar nix
Die sind ja wirklich komplett PP-gatt, die Gegner
Übrigens mit der Shotgun am Treppenaufgang campen
Ich glaube, es gibt keinen First-Person-Shooter, in dem das nicht klappt
Das klappt sogar in Halo, und Halo ist eigentlich kein Rumsitz-Game, das klappt überall
Shotgun, Treppenaufgang, bessere Sache kannst du eigentlich...
Also, fiesere Camper-Positionen gibt es eigentlich kaum in keinem First-Person-Shooter
Das ist wirklich das Abartigste
Überall
Mir fällt eigentlich keiner ein, wo es nicht funktioniert
Overwatch zählt nicht
Weil es ja keine One-In-Shot-Guns gibt
In Battlefield 1 wäre der Typ schon direkt gestorben, wenn er aus dem Fenster gesprungen wäre
Keine Ahnung, die mussten ja irgendwie einen Meter runter springen
Ich meine, es ist realistisch, wenn einer zwei Meter runter springt und sich das Bein verstaucht oder kaputt macht oder sonst wie
Aber in einem Spiel brauche ich das nicht
Und es wäre auch halbwegs realistisch, dass wenn der Typ aus dem dritten Stock springt, dass er ein paar Probleme hat und nicht danach wild Shotgun drum rennt
Aber wer will Realismus
Und am besten war es immer noch in Bad Company 2, wo du aus jedem Fenster deinen Fallschirm erstmal gezogen hast
So nach dem Motto, ich springe aus dem ersten Stockbein im Fallschirm
Trion93, ja
Das kommt manchmal vor mit Ublog
Letzter Zeit
Also Trion fragt hier, ob noch jemand Third-Party-Apps, noch Ad-Unterbrechungen mit Ublog bekommt
Ja, das ist normal aktuell
Die liefern sich da gerade so einen Kampf zwischen Ublog und Twitch und auch teilweise YouTube
Weil die haben natürlich keinen Bock, dass man die Ads blocken kann
Deswegen denken die sich immer neue Dinge aus, dass die Ads doch noch durchgehen
Sachen wie DNS-basierte Ad-Blocker, zum Beispiel P-Hole oder wie heißt der andere?
Ad-Home?
Ne, wie heißt dieses andere Ding?
Adware-Home?
Ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt
Diese DNS-Ad-Blocker, die funktionieren schon gar nicht mehr
Weil Twitch mittlerweile und YouTube auch Cont-Ad-Guard-Home mein ich, genau
Weil Twitch und YouTube und viele andere Contentseiten mittlerweile Content und Werbung vom gleichen Server ausliefern
Die kannst du nicht DNS blocken
Aber Ublog Origin wird da über lange Sicht wieder, denke ich, das reißen
Weil du hast ja einen Vorteil von einem Browser-Ad-On
Es kann den Inhalt der Seite manipulieren und sehen
Also die haben da glaube ich so die Oberhand
Genau, P-Hole funktioniert ewig nicht mehr
Und Ad-Guard-Home auch nicht
Das ist technologiebedingt, geht das gar nicht
Alternativ, was natürlich immer geht, ist
Dings in VLC oder so abspielen
Oh, jetzt sind wir echt professionell mit P-Hole
Oh, jetzt sind wir echt professionell mit Webcam
Das Ding hab ich nie gespielt
Ja, vielleicht ein paar Mal schon, aber jetzt wirklich nie, ernsthaft
Ich fand Shotguns immer übelst low
Dabei macht's bestimmt Bock, wenn du mal so ein 10er-Team wegsprichst
Was machen die denn?
Reagiert mal Leute, bewegt euch
Alter, was ist mit denen los?
So ppega langsam reagieren kannst du doch überhaupt nicht
Guckt euch die Dudes hier jetzt gleich mal an
Komm her
Haben die alle kein Ohr?
Was, VLC hat auch Werbung?
Oh, dann wird's kompliziert, wenn VLC auch Werbung hat
Einfach gerade ausschießen
LMG legit
Aber die machen das richtig, die werfen da Granaten rein
Aber so wirklich connectet da nix
Richtig P-Gar Dauerfeuer
Aber in dem Fall bringt es ja was
Aber die machen das richtig, die werfen da Granaten rein, aber so wirklich connectet
da nichts.
Richtig bepegert Dauerfeuer.
Aber in dem Fall bringt es ja was.
Wie lange soll das noch gehen?
Was gibt es, haben wir eine 50 Billiarden Killstreak.
Nur ein Rückstoß, ja der hat Dings Zweibein und darunter aufgemountet.
Nee, das war auch nicht meins.
A-Cock, A-M-94, Leute ist das eigentlich A-C-O-G oder ist das A-Cock?
Das Konsole, äh, nee ich glaube nicht, dass das Konsole ist, das ist einfach nur 4 zu
3 Seitenverhältnis, warum auch immer.
Wisst ihr was Big Brain wäre, 4 zu 3 spielen und dann 120er Foff, das ergibt zwar überhaupt
keinen Sinn, aber das wärs doch mal oder?
Einfach 4 zu 3 und dafür Foff hoch.
Und dann, und dann, und dann Stretch einschalten im Monitor, Stretch, dass man dann 120er Foff
in 4 zu 3 gestretched auf 16 zu 9 hat.
So müsste man spielen.
Wie sie sich da alle Line-Up, Line-Up haben.
Das ist die Rentner-Loupe, ne da wär das ja eigentlich was für mich.
Ich mach bald Wilhelm-Grammer-LP-Konkurrenz vom Alter her.
Alter, wie sie einfach an, oh, das ist, die lassen sich teilweise so ein bisschen weglatschen.
Ah, schon im Muskel-Shirt, ja, exzellent.
Der Dude, was ist mit dem los?
Warte mal, warte mal.
Kämpt der die Tür ab oder was, der, der kämpt die, der kämpt den Eingang, oder?
Aber anders, da kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen, was der Typ da macht.
Ich glaub, der, ich glaub, der kämpt den anderen Eingang ab.
Lege Hände, da freut er sich, Alter, die rennen aber auch einfach nur, Alter, die rennen,
Alter, ich hab was im Hals, ey, ui, so, exzellent, die rennen dem aber auch gerade rein.
Corona, übrigens, wir haben auf der Arbeit mehr, ich hab euch ja letztens erzählt, wir
haben auf der Arbeit jetzt auch schon den ersten Corona-Fall, wir haben jetzt mehr als
ein Corona-Fall.
Oh, exzellent, man muss natürlich hier oben die Ecke unbedingt, gerade in Battlefield
3, weil Battlefield 3 ist ja auch immer hart, hart kritisch, dass Battlefield 3 genug FPS
hat, da brauchen wir ja die Einblendung oben, ganz, ganz wichtig.
Last Stream, bald ist vorbei, Leute, bald ist vorbei.
Also B, B ist wirklich eine der schwersten M-Coms im ganzen Spiel.
Also, wenn die Gegners gescheit machen, kommst du an B kaum ran.
Noch nicht mal mit einer M16, hallo, gut gemacht, hat er richtig gut gemacht.
Er hat's auch sinnvoll gemacht und ist nicht rausgerannt, gleich hat er die Legehennen
gemacht, sondern hat erstmal geguckt, dass alles leer ist und die Wiederbelebungstypen
weggesprayt, was natürlich auch für bessere K.D. sorgt, ja, K.D., wichtigste Ever.
Battlefield 5 gucken wir nicht, Battlefield 5 gucken wir aus dem Prinzip nicht.
Mir ist übrigens eine Sache aufgefallen, Leute, ich muss dringend, dringend meine
Emotes, mein Emote-Game upsteppen und zwar, ich brauche ganz, ganz, ganz wichtig
People, Love, sonst, sonst geht's nicht, das, das muss schon sein und das Ganze
jetzt natürlich noch transparent, gibt's das auch, gibt's das auch als GIF,
gibt's das auch als GIF, konnte man nicht hier irgendwie noch sagen, GIF, gibt's das
auch animiert, ah, animiert ist ja noch besser, was, animiert oder unanimiert,
was nehmen wir, das ist aber halt so klein, ne, excellent, übrigens zum Thema
Git push habt ihr gesehen, ne, habt ihr nicht gesehen, weil es
followt dem Repo keiner, das, was wir letztens im Stream programmiert haben,
wo der Chat noch zu mir gesagt hat, ich soll's unbedingt pushen, sonst wäre ich
geflamed, ja, ich hab sogar noch mal aktualisiert, dass jetzt Firefox
supported ist und dass der Verbindungsaufbau schneller geht.
Akku abonniert Twitch Prime, dankeschön, excellent Prime Subscription, so, wo
im Moment, wo haben wir's hier, zack, lauig, so, jetzt gucken wir mal, wie gut das, wie
gut das funktioniert, ja geht doch oder, sieht doch ganz hübsch aus, excellent, komm
mal, jetzt lacht ja mein Desktop aus.
So, was gucken wir als nächstes, realer hier sind sinnlose Abwasser, oh, das heben wir
uns mal auf, NFC Smart Home Ideas, Strong Slug,
Kerbal Space Broker, das gucken wir uns jetzt, auch wenn es ein GameStar Video ist, aber
trotzdem, ich fand das erste, den ersten Teil schon mega geil, ich hab's nie
gespielt, aber ich habe total viele Videos geguckt, ich finde das extrem
interessant, das Game, also ich finde das wirklich richtig geil zum
zugucken und da gibt es die übelst abgedrehten
Dinger, wo Leute irgendwelche Flugzeugträger bauen, die auf einen
anderen Planet fliegen und dann dort mit irgendwelchen Shuttles rumdüsen und so
was, total abgedrehtes Zeug, das sind super Videos, die man sich zum
Einschlafen angucken kann, vielleicht spiele ich es ja, wenn es das zweite gibt
auch mal, wenn es den zweiten Teil gibt, vielleicht spiele ich das auch mal, ich
habe bisher Schiss davor gehabt, weil es eben so übelst komplexes Game ist, wo du
erstmal drei Jahre studieren musst, was du spielen kannst.
Wenn man böse wäre, könnte man fragen, wieso braucht es eigentlich ein Kerbal
Spaceprogramm 2? Ja, es soll uns besser ENGIE nennen. Dinger hat in einer nahezu
perfekten Mischung Neulinge wie auch Raumfahrtbegeisterte näher an die
Faszination von Reisen durchs All- und Raketenbau herangeführt. Klar, es gibt
immer Luft nach oben, vor allem optisch, aber viele Mods und sogar die
Unterstützung der NASA haben aus dem kleinen Indie-Stil ein einzigartiges
Erlebnis gemacht. Ob die jetzt auch Earth Chan mit dabei haben?
Reale wissenschaftliche Hintergründe lernen kann. Was soll man da also noch
toppen? Teil 2, der im Herbst 2021 für PC, PlayStation 4, Xbox One und wahrscheinlich
auch für die nächste Generation kommt. Es sieht auf jeden Fall deutlich besser aus als das
alte, oder das ist ein Rendervideo. Also wenn das wirklich so
aussieht, das wäre ja Massive Pog. Mehrere Antworten darauf, und zwar interstellare
Reisen, Kolonien. Aber das ist, dass es pre-rendert. Alle Multiplayer. Oder nicht,
oder doch? Multiplayer? Oh, Multiplayer, da gibt es die ersten Leute, die
irgendwelche... Oh nee, Multiplayer. Leute, ich sag euch, was auf uns zukommt. Ich sag,
ich sag, ich sag, was auf euch zukommt. Wenn das Multiplayer hat, da gibt es die
ersten Leute, die Kerbal Space Program Space Station Roleplay Server machen.
100%! So wie im GTA. Da gibt es dann irgendeine Raumstation, wo Roleplay
gemacht wird. Das kannst du mir so richtig vorstellen.
Der Name Kerbal Space Program steht für Raketenbau bei dem Tankplatzierung
Aerodynamik und Gewichtverteilung wohlbedacht berücksichtigt werden wollen.
Denn nach dem Bau ist vor dem Flug und hier muss die Technik perfekt sitzen,
sonst explodiert unsere Rakete unter dem Hintern weg. Dank zahlreicher Anreize
erkunden wir den Weltraum und statten unter anderem dem Mond einen Besuch ab.
Das funktioniert im Original schon so gut, dass nicht nur wir zunächst von der
Ankündigung zu Teil 2 überrascht waren, sondern auch Philippe Harvester
Falange, der kreative Kopf hinter dem ersten Spiel. Falange arbeitet
mittlerweile nicht mehr beim Kerbal 1. Moment, die machen Teil 2, ohne den
Erfinder oder was?
Und jetzt wird es ein bisschen kompliziert. Hinter dem neuen Spiel
steckt Intercept Games, die wiederum aus Star Theory hervorgegangen sind. Ein
Studio, das im Zuge der Covid-19 Pandemie pleite gegangen war. Klingt also fast
so, als ob die Simulation unter keinem Stern steht. Die Ideen für das
neue Spiel sprechen jedoch eine andere Sprache. Immerhin will Teil 2 genau das
umsetzen, was auch der ursprüngliche... Okay, nur ein Recap, ob ich das richtig
verstanden habe. Also der ursprüngliche Entwickler hat das quasi verkauft mal
an das Studio, ist dort nicht mehr, arbeitet nicht mehr am ursprünglichen
Game mit. Das neue Game wird aber auch nicht von diesem Studio gemacht, sondern
von einem ganz anderen Studio, die während Covid irgendwie halbleite
gegangen sind oder so. What?
Der Erfinder sich für eine Fortsetzung gewünscht hätte, nämlich einen Multiplayer. Dafür wird
das Spiel sogar von Grund auf neu entwickelt. Ja, müssen sie ja. Aber wie genau sollen die
Verbesserungen frischen Ideen nun funktionieren? Schauen wir uns das doch
mal im Detail an. Das sah so ein bisschen nach Unity aus.
Also es war jetzt einfach nur meine Vermutung, weil es Visual Studio war und
C-Sharp und Visual Studio halt ganz gut funzt. Ich meine, es kann genauso gut C++ und
Unreal sein. Aber C++, wer gibt sich das freiwillig? Wie schon im
Vorgänger starten wir unsere Reise auf dem Planeten Kerbin, der unserer Erde
ähnelt. Von dort aus erkunden wir unser kleines Sonnensystem und noch mehr.
Es sieht auf jeden Fall deutlich detailreicher aus als das letzte. Das
letzte hat einfach nur flachen Boden. Denn anders als Teil 1 bietet Kerbin
Space Program 2 interstellare Raumfahrten. Auf den verhältnismäßig
nahegelegenen Planeten werden wir Ressourcen finden, mit denen wir die
entsprechende Technik für die Weitenflüge entwickeln können.
Bedeutet im Klartext, der umfangreiche Baukasten, mit dem wir unsere Raketen
entwerfen, wird noch deutlich umfangreicher und erlaubt es uns
erstmals unser eigenes Sonnensystem zu verlassen. Und die Entwickler haben...
Wisst ihr was passieren könnte? Dass die sagen, es gibt keinen Mod-Support mehr
und das Spiel ist dead nach zwei Monaten, weil eines der Sachen, die
halt Spiele am Leben halten, wie das, ist halt Mod-Support.
Drei Raum bei der Gestaltung der Himmelskörper. So verspricht Intercept
Games mit Char beispielsweise ein Planeten, der ausschließlich aus heißem
Eisen besteht. Owen gleicht hingegen der Erde, besitzt nur eine viel größere
Anziehungskraft und Rask und Rusk ziehen sich immer wieder gegenseitig an.
Bilder zu den Planeten gibt es noch nicht, doch allein auf diesen extremen
Orten zu landen, stellen wir uns verdammt schwer und verdammt unterhaltsam vor.
Immerhin ist bereits eine Landung auf einem einfachen Himmelskörper wie dem
Moden in der Realität... Das Spiel, das hat ein paar lustige Bugs zum
Beispiel, kann man aus Hitzeschilden Propeller bauen, die besser funktionieren
als alle anderen Propeller, weil Hitzeschilde irgendwie mehr Auftrieb
erzeugen. Also es ist schon so ein bisschen Wissenschaft für sich, das Game, hat auch
oftmals mit der Realität überhaupt nichts mehr zu tun, aber ich gucke mir
die Videos echt extrem gern an.
Realitätsnanphysik alles andere als leicht. Nur wie genau diese Reisen
funktionieren werden, bleibt eine spannende und wichtige Frage. In der
Realität haben solche Ziele eine Hand von Problemen, weswegen bislang auch nur
theoretische Konzepte zu Fahrten in andere Sonnensysteme existieren. Das fängt
beispielsweise schon bei der Geschwindigkeit an.
Damit ein Flugkörper überhaupt in einer Zeit von Jahrzehnten oder Jahrhunderten
in einem fremden Planetensystem ankommt, müsste er einen nicht gerade geringen
Anteil der Lichtgeschwindigkeit... Der macht doch nichts. Einfach Zeit
vorspulen ist in dem Game doch kein Problem....bei der Reise erreichen. Nur mal so zum
Vergleich. Eine der schnellsten Raketen, die Parker Solar Probe, kommt maximal auf
308 Kilometer pro Sekunde. Das Licht liegt in derselben Sekunde fast
300.000 Kilometer zurück. Es bleibt also spannend, wie genau... Man muss dazu sagen, die
Parker Solar Probe ist keine Rakete, sondern eine Sonde, die natürlich mit
einer Rakete gestartet wurde, aber ich muss noch ein bisschen klugscheißen.
...Kurbel 2 das umsetzen will, ohne den Realismusanspruch völlig zu verlieren.
Und dass es ein wenig mehr Kreativität einsetzen will, zeigt sich auch bei der
Nächsten Neuerung, den Kolonien. Die sind im übrigen auch unerlässlich für
interstellare Fahrten, denn um die nötigen Ressourcen zu erhalten, müssen
die erst einmal gefunden und abgebaut werden.
Oh, Crafting. Okay, ob sie da Crafting einbauen müssten, ist einmal dahingestellt.
...Zwischen zwei Sonnensystemen benötigen. Wir errichten die neuen
Außenposten auf anderen Planeten und walten so nebenbei auch den Lebensraum
unserer Kurbels aus. Die Kolonien liefern uns also nicht nur neue, wichtige und
vermutlich fiktionale Rohstoffe, sondern dienen auch als neue Basen. Haben wir ein
Himmelskörper erfolgreich kolonisiert, bauen wir in Zukunft auch dort neue
Raketen und schießen sie von hier aus in den neuen Orbit. So sparen wir es uns
jedes Mal von Kurbeln zu starten und erschließen die Weiten des Alls
deutlich komfortabler. Aber so eine Kolonie will auch erst einmal gebaut
werden und das allein soll laut Entwickler eine riesige Herausforderung
werden. Und wie ebenfalls bereits angesprochen, will Kurbel Space
Program 2 uns und Serien Erfinder Falangi endlich den Wunsch erfüllen, gemeinsam
mit Freunden ins All zu reisen. Dank neuem Multiplayer... Also ich glaube, Multiplayer
können wirklich nice sein....mehr als dieses Statement haben die
Macher aber zum Mehrspielermodus noch nicht verraten. Wie genau der Raketenbau,
das Manövrieren im luftleeren Raum oder das Erforschen zu zweit ausfällt, bleibt
für den Moment noch unklar. Ebenfalls, ob wir wirklich nur zu zweit bleiben oder
sogar noch mehr Kollegen einladen dürfen. Boah, sieht ein bisschen schepp aus.
Erschreckt. Ansonsten bleibt sich der zweite Teil der Reihe treu. Er will auf
eine noch bessere Physik Simulation setzen, um den neuesten Erkenntnissen der
Raumfahrt zu entsprechen und das Spiel bestraft uns mit Explosionen und
Zerstörung, wenn wir diese Physik missachten. Zusätzlich sollen Neueinsteiger
deutlich besser ins komplexe Spiel eingeführt werden. Zwar hat der Vorgänger
bereits sehr hilfreiche Tutorials bereitgestellt, aber die haben nicht
alle Aspekte ausführlich abgedeckt, manche sogar gar nicht. Das soll sich nun
ändern. Animierte Tutorials sollen uns verständlich beibringen, wie alles
genau funktioniert. Eine übersichtlichere Nutzeroberfläche soll den
Bedienkomfort zudem erhöhen und neue Konstruktions- und Fluganweisungen sollen
uns besser an die Hand nehmen. So werden wir hoffentlich wesentlich flotter zum
Raumfahrt-Experten ohne viele Details selbst mühselig herausfinden zu müssen.
Also ich finde die Grafik sieht auch eine ganze Ecke realistischer aus. Also
vom Style her finde ich, als das beim anderen der Fall war. Bis du Max FPS
Exposed! Jetzt ist es raus.
Vielleicht muss ja doch nicht alles bis ins kleinste Detail erklärt werden.
Liegt! Liegt!
Eins steht schon jetzt fest. Einen Schönheitspreis wird auch Kerbal Space
Program 2 nicht gewinnen, selbst wenn es viel besser als Teil 1 aussieht. Aber
darum geht es hier ja auch gar nicht, denn schließlich bleibt die komplexe
Physik weiter das Herzstück der Weltraumbausimulation und die muss
wiederum in erster Linie nur zweckmäßig aussehen und dafür aber
vor allem gut funktionieren. Die interstellaren Reisen und Kolonien
können zudem die Abwechslung einer Partie deutlich erhöhen, da wir so auf
mehr Widerstände und Herausforderungen stoßen, ohne ständig wieder auf demselben
Planeten starten zu müssen. Stichwort Planet. Die Idee exotischer
Himmelskörper klingt auf dem Papier ebenfalls klasse, muss sich aber noch
genau wie der Multiplayer im Praxistest beweisen. Und das ist auch der Knackpunkt.
Auf dem Papier klingt Kerbal Space Program 2 fantastisch und hat definitiv
das Zeug seinen Vorgänger zu übertrumpfen. Aber wir wissen schlicht noch nicht, wie
die Kampagne aussehen wird, wie gut die Physiksimulation letztendlich läuft und
Ja, wann soll es denn rauskommen? Wann ist denn Release?
Fans und Interessierte sollten das Spiel aber unbedingt im Auge behalten, denn
auch wenn eine 2 im Marsch steht, erwartet uns sehr wahrscheinlich wieder ein sehr
einzigartiges Erlebnis.
Wann soll denn das sein?
Drittes Quartal 2000. Okay, das wird eh nicht gehalten, das wird eh nicht gehalten.
Wann kommt denn jetzt eigentlich Cyberpunk raus? Das haben sie ja wieder verschoben.
Wann ist es denn jetzt so weit? 19. November, also sprich so ungefähr
zweieinhalb Wochen. Hey, das wird ja genau passen, in zweieinhalb Wochen habe ich
Urlaub. Excellent. Ach stimmt, die haben es ja noch mal verschoben. Stimmt, jaja, ich dachte,
das wäre jetzt schon verschoben worden. Google lügt. Google lacks critical
information. Das ist richtig. Hier neunter, neunter Dezember. Können Sie sich jetzt mal
entscheiden? Hier steht neunter Dezember und da steht zehnte Dezember. Vielleicht
Zeitzonenunterschied. Aber es ist eigentlich die falsche Richtung für Zeitzonen. Machst du
in deinem Urlaub ein paar Videos? Ja, mache ich. Habe ich am Anfang vom Stream schon
gesagt. Jede Menge. Aber die mache ich davor, die mache ich davor, die lade ich
nur im Dezember hoch. Ich, wie gesagt, das Ganze wird es nur geben, wenn ich
wirklich das schaffe, die ganzen Videos vorher aufzunehmen. Ich fange nicht an
mit, ich nehme nur zehn Videos auf und nehme den Rest danach auf, weil das mache ich
da wieder nicht.
Übrigens eine Sache, ne, was gerade, was gerade 2020 mit der Extrem angesagt ist,
kennt ihr die Leute, die quasi immer, egal, wenn was passiert und sei es nur,
dass der Kühlschrank kaputt geht oder irgendwie, man Kaffee auf der Treppe
verschüttet oder sowas. Die Leute, die dann immer sagen, 2020, jetzt passiert das
auch noch. 2020, das jetzt ist wirklich das schlimmste Jahr aller Zeiten. 2020.
Schlimmer geht es ja nicht mehr. Bei jedem, bei jedem, bei jedem Furz ist 2020
das schlimmste Jahr aller Zeiten. Jetzt ist auch noch, jetzt ist auch noch James Bond
gestorben, 2020. Meine Güte, 2020. Das ist aus meiner Sicht kompletter Blödsinn.
Es passiert in jedem Jahr Scheiße, aber die Leute erinnern sich einfach nicht mehr
dran. Und ich sage euch, spätestens 2021 passieren auch wieder Scheißdinger, so
dass sich an 2020 auch keiner mehr erinnert. Weil Corona bleibt uns 2021
auch erhalten, auf jeden Fall. Das ist ja nicht einfach weg. Deswegen ist ja auch
das witzige, wenn sie jetzt sagen, ja Corona, es ist ja kein Lockdown, das ist
halt Slowdown. Sorry, falls ich jetzt hier das falsche Wort verwendet habe.
Also der Corona-Slowdown im November, das ist ja nur zeitlich beschränkt auf
November. So ein Blödsinn. Ich wurde ja schon wieder ein bisschen geflamed auf Twitter.
Das habe ich ja vor ein paar Tagen auf Twitter geschrieben, so nachdem, und ihr glaubt
doch selber nicht. Wie soll denn das gehen? Wir machen jetzt November-Lockdown
und im Dezember heißt dann, okay, jetzt haben wir einen Monat Lockdown, jetzt ist
alles wieder gut, alles perfekt, wir machen jetzt Weihnachtsmarkt auf. Oder
wie stellen die sich das vor? Das wird selbstverständlich verlängert werden.
Deswegen, ich bin ja ein Fan davon, wenn man mit offenen Karten spielt, wenn man
nicht versucht, die Leute zu verarschen, wenn man den Leuten einfach sagt, wie es ist.
Wenn man sagt, hey, wir haben uns jetzt dafür entschieden, das um das zu machen und
das bleibt so lange in Kraft, wie wir es für mit den Zahlen sinnvoll erachten.
Das ist bestimmt nicht zeitlich beschränkt, das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen.
Es wäre komplett bescheuert davon auszugehen, dass Ende November cut ist und
es ist alles wieder wie vorher. Das ist einfach Standard-Taktik, die man
bei vielen Sachen macht und was auch das Problem ist, warum man eigentlich so
gut wie nicht glauben kann, was einem erzählt wird, weil viele Sachen einfach
aufgeweischt werden.
Nach dem Motto, man sagt heute, es ist so und in zwei Wochen sagt man, ist doch
nicht so. Das führt über lange Zeit dazu, dass keiner mehr was glaubt.
Bestes Beispiel ist, dass mit diesen Zetteln, ihr kennt das ja, wenn man
irgendwo ins Restaurant geht, also das hat sich jetzt ja erledigt.
Das ist ja, Restaurant gehen ist ja vorbei und da muss man diese Zettel
ausfüllen und ich glaube, die meisten Leute haben das relativ gewissenhaft
gemacht mit dem Zettel ausfüllen. Denke ich mal, ein paar haben da wahrscheinlich
draufgeschrieben, Peter Wubbel war hier oder so, aber die meisten haben das
schon, denke ich, halbwegs gewissenhaft ausgefüllt, weil es bringt einem selber
was und es bringt anderen auch was und da hat man das sich so angeschaut und hat gesagt,
ok, passt, aber jetzt in Bayern, weiß nicht, wie man das Zettel
Gastronomie Bayern, die fangen jetzt an,
das aufzuweichen und zwar, wo immer es steht, die haben jetzt angefangen, genau
hier, sowas, die haben jetzt angefangen, dass die Polizei Zugriff auf diese
Corona-Listen kriegt. Am Anfang hat man gesagt, unabhängig von diesem einen Fall,
ob ich das jetzt gut oder schlecht finde, aber man hat von Anfang an gesagt, diese
Corona-Zettel sind zweckgebunden und diese Corona-Zettel werden nur für den
Fall verwendet, zum Nachverfolgen von Infektionsketten. Wenn man da jetzt ein
paar Wochen später anfängt und sagt, die Polizei bekommt Zugriff drauf,
unabhängig davon, ob das jetzt vielleicht in dem einen Fall gut oder
schlecht ist, dann man macht sich einfach komplett un glaubwürdig, aber total.
Das ist total un glaubwürdig und wenn man das behauptet und eine Woche später
wieder auf oder ein paar Wochen später wieder verwässert, führt es dazu, dass
nichts mehr eingehalten wird, weil die Leute sich denken, was ihr uns heute
erzählt, ist eh morgen Schall und Rauch, also halten wir uns jetzt schon mal nicht
dran, weil wir wissen ja gar nicht, was damit passieren wird. Es ist total
bescheuert, es ist wirklich total beknackt, sich so zu verhalten, es ist für
alle Seiten bescheuert. Es geht mir gar nicht so sehr darum, so diese
übliche Geschichte, wo immer so Stammtischmiedchen erzählt werden, die lügen uns ja eh
alle nur an, es ist für alle Beteiligten schlecht, weil es dazu führt, dass die
Leute sich an nichts mehr halten, weil du dich nicht auf die Aussagen verlassen
kannst und das ist halt ein ziemlicher Sack. Also sprich, wenn man sagt, die
Corona-Daten sind zweckgebunden oder irgendwelche Gesundheitsdaten sind
zweckgebunden und sonst was, dann müssen die zweckgebunden sein, weil wenn du dich
da nicht mehr drauf verlassen und das heißt auch nicht, in einem halben Jahr
machen wir dann was anderes, es ist vollkommen egal, ob das
rechtlich oder nicht rechtlich haltbar ist, es geht einfach um die
Wirkung von so einer Aussage, wenn ich jetzt mich hinstelle und sag, überlegt
euch mal Leute, ich stell mich jetzt hin und sag, Leute, ich mach ab heute jeden
Tag ein Video und dann mach ich kein Video. So, nächste Woche sag ich wieder, Leute, ich
mach jeden Tag ein Video, ich mach wieder kein Video. So, in der dritten
Woche sag ich dann, Leute, aber jetzt, jetzt mach ich wirklich jeden Tag ein
Video, glaubt ihr mir dann noch, dass ich wirklich ein Video mach? Und so läuft das
da auch und das ist fatal aus meiner Sicht, weil dann sich auch an
sinnvolle Sachen nicht gehalten wird, weil man schon im Vorfeld davon ausgeht, dass
die Sache eh wieder umgewurstet wird. Natürlich, Chat, ja, ich weiß. Ja, und die
Frage, da kann ich ganz kurz was dazu sagen, MrRealHead, übrigens exquisite
Name, MrSixHead wäre glaube ich noch besser, also MrRealHead6, und zwar, ich muss mal kurz den Chat noch machen, da sag ich nur
ganz kurz was zu, weil sonst artet das hier wieder aus, wenn ich mich dazu
lang zu auslasse. Was ich von der ganzen Corona-Politik halte, also
vieles finde ich nicht gut. Ich habe nichts gegen Corona-Maßnahmen an sich.
Ich glaube auch, dass es Viren gibt. Es wird ja immer so hingestellt, als kann man
nur komplett für die Corona-Maßnahmen sein oder man leugnet, dass es Viren
gibt, was ja auch wieder schwachsinnig ist, weil die Welt ist nun mal nicht
schwarz und weiß, also sprich, es gibt noch was dazwischen zwischen, ich finde
alles geil, und es gibt keine Viren, weil um wirklich ernsthaft zu behaupten, dass
es keine Viren gibt, da musste ja jegliche die letzten 200 Jahre Forschung
komplett leugnen, was beknackt ist, ja, aber ich finde nicht alle Corona-Maßnahmen gut.
Was ich, mein größter Kritikpunkt ist, gar nicht so sehr die Corona-Maßnahmen an
sich, sondern mein größter Kritikpunkt, den ich persönlich mit den Corona-Maßnahmen
habe, ist, dass die alle nicht richtig erklärt sind, warum was gemacht, zum
Beispiel, warum machen Fitnessstudios zu, warum darf keiner mehr Tennis oder
Golf spielen und solche Geschichten.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich weiß nicht, ob es beim aktuellen Lockdown so ist, beim
letzten war es so, wo ist die Erklärung dafür?
Das ist das, was ich irgendwie vermisse. Gegen die Corona-Maßnahmen an sich habe
ich gar nichts, ich vermisse die Erklärung, wie man zu der Abwägung gekommen
ist, das zu machen, ja. Programm, was Programmier-Idee für den Schrim?
Erweiterung des Meambots um eine Statistik und zum Beispiel, wie oft
lange die mit, das ist eine gute Idee, Wasserfreak, aber das Meambot an sich ist
eh total kaputt, also wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise Text-to-Speech verwende,
dann kackt er teilweise ab, wenn ich es nicht richtig mache, das müsste ich, das
müsste ich mal wirklich ordentlich fixen alles, da könnte ich auch releasen auf
GitHub oder so und dann könnte man sich drüber überlegen, ob man da nicht
irgendwas einbaut, aber jetzt ist, glaube ich, das einzubauen geht erstmal nicht.
Das mit Tennis-Spielen ist nicht so klar, Tennis darf man nicht überall
spielen. Je nachdem in welchem Bundesland du bist, ist Tennis-Spielen erlaubt oder
nicht erlaubt oder in freiem, in der Halle verboten, in Freiluft erlaubt, das
ist nicht so, nicht so einfach. Das ist unglaublich komplex, um raus zu
bekommen, ob man noch Tennis spielen darf aktuell. Glaubt man gar nicht, aber ist so.
Das ist auch so, es ist auch ein Kritikpunkt, den ich an, wie das
Corona technisch gehandhabt wird, habe, ist, dass zu viel, zu schnell sich ändert.
Wenn es mal ein paar Regeln geben würde, die auch mal ein bisschen länger
Bestand haben und so, dass ich nicht jeden Tag neu gucken muss, was ich machen
darf und was nicht, wäre der Sache auch geholfen.
Ja, aber mehr will ich mich jetzt gar nicht dazu auslassen, das geht mir eh
schon auf den Sack, dass überall nur noch Corona angesagt ist. Wenn du hier
Youtube aufmachst, zuerst was kriegst, Covid-19-News, Corona aktuell, 14.000
aktuelle Zahlen zu Corona. Corona-Diktatur, die AfD darf natürlich
nicht fehlen bei. Neue Corona-Beschränkungen, Folgen für die, das ist natürlich,
wirst du überall zugekleistert, ohne Ende. Muss ich jetzt hier auch noch machen.
Jack, Gamer, 21, exzellent Subscribtion. Huge.
Ich muss gerade mal Chat durchscrollen, aber ich glaube, ich hab noch
einen Zapf übersehen. Leco, drei Monate, dankeschön. Exquisite
Subscription. Huge. Massive Brainzapf. Mr. Realheader1, Twitch Prime,
dankeschön für den Zapf. Der Scamtrain ist am Start, seh ich jetzt erst.
Jibaytrain. Kannst du das neue Demon's Souls Gameplay angucken? Kann ich machen.
Was ist, was ist das neue? Das da? Passt mal auf, ich zeig euch jetzt den
krassesten YouTube Hack dieses Jahrtausends. Nur, nur echte Hacker-Mans können das machen.
YouTube-Mitarbeiter hassen diesen Trick. Bam, und schon läuft's.
Boah, war das für ein Sound gerade. Das war der PS5 Sound, ein bisschen leicht
übersteuert, oder? Amazing, krasser Hack, oder? Das originale Demon's
Souls hab ich gespielt, aber das war echt nicht mein Fall. Oder hab ich die, gab's
vor Demon's Souls noch was? Ich hab irgendein Souls-Game mal gespielt, ich glaub das war
Demon's Souls, irgendwas auf der 360 noch. Das war, dann war's was. Oder PS3? Nee, dann
war's was anderes. Ich hab's auf der, ich hab's ziemlich sicher auf der Xbox gespielt.
Vielleicht war's das erste Dark Souls-Game. Das war, war nicht so mein Fall, muss ich
euch ehrlich sagen. Ja gut, durch diese komischen Nebel-Dinger.
MonkaS. Spodas, Spodas.
Der darf's mal schön auf den Schwanz hauen, jawoll. Exzellent.
Ob sich das, nee, nee, ich sag's jetzt nicht. MonkaToss.
Hatte, hatte Demon's Souls nicht so ein komisches Movement-System, so ein ganz merkwürdiges,
ähm, mit, was war denn das? Ansonsten hat's ja in Dark Souls, in Dark Souls
PS3 zum größten halt einfach nur rumgerollt. Ähm, was? Das ist schon ewig her.
Wie? Get wrecked?
Aber optisch haben sie's schon echt hübsch gemacht.
Erstmal weggeknübbelt. Weggecockt.
Also, schockt mich jetzt nicht so wirklich das Gameplay.
Es sieht extrem hübsch aus, das muss man sagen. Die Gegner haben allgemein keine Schadensmodelle,
oder? Da bricht nix ab. Also, wenn er da rumschlägt,
wenn er den rumschlägt, der, der Mob sieht am Ende, nachdem er da ein paar Mal drauf
gehauen hat, genauso aus wie am Anfang. Man gerade so Steinwürmer könnten schon ein
bisschen kaputt gehen, wenn man drauf haut.
Muss ich ja sagen, was mir an Dark Souls am besten gefallen hat, ist, ähm, also, ich
geh jetzt einfach mal voraus, dass es Dark Souls war. Aber auch, was man von den Games
so sieht, ist gar nicht so mal das, das eigentliche, also, als jemand, der wirklich nur ein bisschen
ein, ein, ein Spiel, der Serie gespielt hat, ich finde das Gegnerdesign, finde ich optisch
echt cool. Jetzt das hier nicht so wirklich, aber da gibt's richtig geile Gegner. Und
die Sound, und der Soundtrack ist, ist übelst nice. Da gibt's doch, wie heißt der Endgegner
aus dem ersten Moment, oder einer der letzten Gegner, ähm, das ist übelst Dark Souls
Nord, das da, das ist exquisite Soundtrack.
Der Soundtrack ist, ist wirklich nice. Und die haben viele geile Sachen im, im, im Dark
Souls Soundtrack. Was aber auch poggers ist, ist das Ori-Main-Theme, das ist auch. Nee,
nicht das. Das. Das ist da, das ist exzellent. Wie Shopmusik, ja, wie Shopmusik ist, an
anderes Kaliber, ja. Beste.
So, und jetzt, äh, nachdem wir jetzt die, die Pepe-Hand-Soundtracks haben, kommt noch
die, die viel Shopmusik.
So, okay, genug, wir gucken jetzt weiter. Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Haben, haben wir überhaupt gerade ein Video geguckt schon?
Haben wir gerade schon was geguckt, oder bin ich jetzt... Lowbrain, ich glaub wir haben
gar nichts geguckt. Das Demon-Souls-Gameplay, ja, ahja.
Jetzt übertreiben sie es mit dem Soundtrack aber fast schon, ey.
Wie er sich baschen lässt.
Lowbrain, sechs Monate, dankeschön. Exzellent.
Mag schon RTX 3090 gekauft, mein Factory ist lieferbar, exzellent, Moment, Sekunde, Sekunde,
ich muss, ich muss, äh, Grafikkarte bestellen.
Pock, ganz schön teuer, soll die normalerweise nicht bloß eins drei kosten?
Sehe ich grad vierhundert Euro teurer als sonst? Ah ne, eins fünf.
Ist ja ein Schnapper für 1800 Euro, dafür kriegst du einen kompletten Rechner.
Wie maximale Bestellmenge eins. Ich dachte ich könnte jetzt mindestens vier
bestellen. Ja, dass man sich auch ein wenig den Kontostand
sich bewegen sieht. Hast du die AMD-Karten gesehen?
Ja, ich hab, äh, das Benchmark-Bild gesehen, das AMD sagt sie sind schneller als Nvidia.
Oder ab 31 Euro im Monat, über 72 Monate, was sind denn 72? Sechs Jahre, sechs Jahre.
Ok, ich bezahle, ok, ich bezahle 400 Euro mehr, ich bezahle 400 Euro mehr und muss sechs Jahre
lang eine Grafikkarte abbezahlen. Ne, das ist nicht Five Head, das ist ehrlich
gesagt Massive Low Brain, wenn man das macht. Wenn man kein Geld hat, sich sowas zu kaufen,
dann sollte man es einfach lassen. Das ist eh das Beste, was man machen kann.
Man muss einfach mehr Geld behalten als Geld aufgeben und schon wird man reich.
Und vor allem ärgert man sich nach drei Jahren, wenn man 30 Euro im Monat bezahlen muss, für
eine Grafikkarte, die man schon gar nicht mehr verwendet.
Packt dann richtig ab. Ja, was, ich bestell mir das jetzt nicht.
Ab wann gibt es denn? Wann gibt es denn den?
5. November, also nächste Woche. Nächste Woche Donnerstag.
Es ist die Frage halt, wie lieferbar der ganze Kram ist.
Ich könnte eh mal bei Hardware Rat fragen, ob der mir irgendwie eine CPU und eine Grafikkarte
besorgen kann. Ich mein bezahlen tue ich es natürlich selbst,
aber der kommt da wahrscheinlich besser ran, als wenn ich die jetzt über irgendwelche
Shops preorder für 50% mehr preis. Wisst ihr was neues zu liegen?
Ja, wenn der Kram endlich lieferbar ist, schon. Der Kommentator für 11 Monate, du bist ja
ein Monat vor. Mal gucken, ob die Ryzen-Dinger dann auch lieferbar
sind. Wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Ist ja immer so ein Ding, wenn neue Sachen rauskommen, dauert es erst mal zwei, drei
Monate bis der Kram überhaupt, bis man die Möglichkeit hat für viel zu viel Kohle was
zu kaufen. Also sollte, sollte die neuen AMD-CPUs lieferbar
sein, dann baue ich mir dieses Jahr im Dezember noch einen neuen Rechner.
Also wenn das wirklich lieferbar ist, dann gucke ich, dass ich einen 5950X kriege mit
dem passenden Board, ordentlich RAM und dann mache ich eine, vielleicht mache ich sogar
mal eine AMD-Grafikkarte wieder rein, je nachdem, ob es bis dahin unabhängige Tests gibt.
Onstream zusammenbauen, das wird schwierig. Was ist das?
Speed und Feature, also komm zwischen 20.04 und 20.02 hat sich nicht sonderlich viel getan.
Was hältst du vom Hermann Miller Logitech G Gaming Chair?
Ach du große Kacke, nee, habe ich noch nie gesehen, zeig mal her.
Welche, das da? Sieht schon mal komisch aus.
Warum ist denn das auf, Schwedisch oder so? Norwegisch?
Ach exzellent, Gamer Grill als Model erstmal genommen, weil auch das wahrscheinlich die
meisten sind nicht drauf. Wow, okay.
Dann bleibe ich lieber bei meinem, der war ein bisschen billiger und ist der beste Stuhl,
den es gibt. Also ich könnte mir keinen besseren Stuhl
vorstellen als den hier. Der kostet halt auch, also das hier würde
ich nicht dafür ausgeben, sondern ich würde irgendwie gucken, dass ich die ein bisschen
günstiger kriege, wenn gerade irgendwelche Shops den Kram verkaufen, ich habe es auch
ein bisschen günstiger gekriegt. Aber wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen
dem und dem für den Preis, ich würde ohne Scheiß, ich würde meinen wieder kaufen, das
ist der beste Stuhl, den ich je hatte, der ist extrem bequem, du kannst, dein Link ist
noch teurer, mein Link ist ein uralter Amazon Link, 1800 sogar, voll für den Arsch.
Der ist der beste, wie gesagt, der beste Stuhl, den ich je hatte hier, das Ding hier.
Der ist extrem bequem, extrem stabil, super einstellbar, verstellbar an allen Geschichten,
da gibt es nichts zu merken. Ja, beste. Wir haben sogar einen Link für den
Staubsauger, den wir nicht alles haben. Ok, ich gucke jetzt mal, realer Irrsinn.
Was hältst du von DX Racer? Nix, ich hatte mal einen DX Racer und da ist ernsthaft der,
die Armlehne aus dem Rahmen rausgebrochen, weil sie nicht richtig festgeschweißt war
oder so. Ich bin aufgestanden und man steht ja mit
ein bisschen Schmackes auf, man steht ja quasi auf, indem man sich zur Hälfte von der Armlehne
abdrückt. Aber man steht auch so, zack, Armlehne und steht auf und da bin ich halt einmal zackig
aufgestanden und die Armlehne vom DX Racer ist aus dem Rahmen rausgebrochen an irgendeiner
Lötzstelle oder so. Seitdem halte ich Abstand von DX Racer.
Im Bauernhof der Gerstenhauer. Ja, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder
zu extrem Peppofett oder DX Racer Kakwali. Man muss sagen, nachdem ich es ja schaffe,
mich mit dem Arm abzustützen und ich kein 300 Kilo Gewichtheber bin, würde ich mal behaupten,
rein am Gewicht, wenn ich das mit dem Arm gestemmt kriege, kann es nicht liegen, wo
jetzt noch übrig bleibt, eigentlich nur noch DX Racer Müll.
Was hat denn der Opa da für ein krasses Mobil, ey?
Aha, exzellent. Gulli, absolut Hightech.
Ah, exquisite. Der Opa ist geil.
Es ist quasi ein Smart-Abwasser-Kanal.
Wow, Poggers.
Nutzt dich dein Stuhl schnell ab. Nein, den habe ich schon fünf oder sechs oder sieben
oder so Jahre und der funktioniert wunderbar.
Exzellent, da kann Unity Media gleich Glasfaser verlegen.
Das war es doch auch schon. Das wäre es dann nicht, weil der Hof ein natürliches Gefälle
hat.
Also Sicht ist jetzt richtig, die wollen eben ein neues Abwasserrohr einbauen, obwohl
er eigentlich schon ein Abwasserrohr hat, was im gleichen Fluss rauskommt. Das klingt
ja typisch nach Deutschlandbürokratie.
Wasser nicht bergauf fließt, müsste eine Hebeanlage eingebaut werden und das kostet
dann richtig Geld.
Tja, Geld ist eben wie Wasser, es muss fließen. Schließlich hat der Abwasserzweckverband
von Anfang an
Der Abwasserzweckverband, also sowas haben auch nur wir
alles bestens durchdacht.
Über die Verhältnismäßigkeit des Baus einer Hebeanlage lässt sich streiten.
Ja, sieben Jahre lang, aber jetzt dürfen die Gerstenhauers ihr altes System doch noch
behalten. Die Anschlussgebühren von 2000 Euro zahlen sie natürlich trotzdem.
Alte Bauernhof-Weisheit, steter Tropfen höhlt den Geldbeutel.
Alter, was, das wollten sie ja ultralustige Wortwitzchen wieder einbauen.
Ja, aber sowas haben wir auch bloß wir so im Schwachsinn.
Das ist halt richtig fail.
Das hat sich verhältnismäßig schnell geklärt, wahrscheinlich weil das Fernseher am Start
war.
Ansonsten hätte sich das nicht so schnell geklärt.
TTH Assassin, nee, doch, Assassin sagt er arbeitet in der Branche und was da manchmal
abgeht.
Es ist in vielen Bereichen so, dass extrem viel sinnloses Zeug gemacht wird, bei uns
auf der Arbeit auch.
Ich mein, klar, wenn man jetzt mit irgendwelchen öffentlichen Sachen zu tun hat, dann mit Sicherheit
noch mehr.
Gibt's extra drei zu Hanau, weiß ich nicht, gibt's, keine Ahnung.
Gerade bei öffentlichen Sachen ist es noch eklicher, weil der Typ, der dort da sitzt
und darüber entscheidet, den betrifft das halt persönlich absolut nicht und da muss
auch im Zweifelsfall nicht damit rechnen, dass er seinen Job verliert, wenn er scheiße
entscheidet.
Das ist natürlich bei mir auf der Arbeit nicht ganz so extrem, wenn da jemand extrem
scheiße entscheidet und extrem scheiße baut, dann hat es auch Einfluss auf ihn selbst,
weil er vielleicht weg ist und er hat ein gewisses Interesse daran, nicht extreme Scheiße
zu entscheiden und zu machen, aber bei uns werden auch übelst unsinnige Sachen gemacht.
Habe ich euch schon erzählt, dass wir jetzt Linux-Systeme haben, auf denen der Windows
Defender läuft, ist jetzt kein Witz, es gibt ja Windows Defender jetzt für Linux, ah ne,
sorry, Microsoft Defender für Linux, wir haben jetzt Linux-Systeme, die laufen mit
Microsoft Defender und das ist kein Witz zum Thema, man macht auch sinnlose Sachen und
wisst ihr wo das herkommt, dass ich euch jetzt mal die Stonks-Weisheiten erklären kann,
wie man auf so eine Idee kommt, das überhaupt zu machen und zwar, wir hatten das Problem,
es hat sich irgendjemand, hat sich ein Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner bei uns eingefangen und er hat ein paar
Windows-Server-Systeme befallen, nicht von unsere Linux-Dinger war betroffen, muss man
dazu sagen, die Linux-Dinger waren komplett safe und jetzt hat man sich Berater von Microsoft
ins Haus geholt, um diesem Problem Herr zu werden und diesem Problem vorzubeugen und
die Microsoft-Mitarbeiter haben gesagt, ja, damit wir sinnvoll euch helfen können, muss
man auf alle Systeme Windows-Defender drauf, man hat jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten gehabt, entweder
man schickt die Microsoft-Leute wieder heim und sagt, oder man installiert auf alle Linux-Systeme,
die keine Probleme hatten, auch Windows-Defender, was meint ihr, was man davon gemacht hat,
ja, das ist richtige Stonksentscheidung wieder, also es wird auch viel Schwachsinn entschieden,
aber das hat ja wenigstens nichts mit öffentlichen Beamtern und so zu tun, da ist natürlich die
Sache noch schlimmer.
Die Berater von Microsoft sind big brain, warum hat er too smart eigentlich nicht hier
als E-Mode gemacht, Moment, hat er etwa die E-Modes ausgeschaltet hier, was ist da los,
warum gehen meine E-Modes nicht, was soll das, Anzeige ist raus, E-Modes, Addons, Betatwitch-TV-E-Modes,
Ach, ich hab die Betatwitch-TV-E-Modes nicht enabled, exellent, so und jetzt muss man noch
sagen, Animated, GIF, Moment, wo macht man nochmal Animated, E-Modes an, wo war das nochmal
versteckt, hast du bei dem RTSP-Web-RTC-Kram weitergemacht, ja das funktioniert jetzt auch
in Firefox und der Verbindungsaufbau ist schneller, ich hab gestern oder vorgestern noch was gepusht,
hier GIF, Animated GIF-E-Modes, exellent, okay probieren wir mal aus, rare, ihh, aber
man hat's schon gesehen, das funktioniert, ah, hat jetzt animiert, sehr gut, exquisite,
sehr schön, so machen wir das, eh, bestes E-Mode, was die wehe, das wird's sein, genau,
wir hatten auf unsere Linux-Probleme, äh, Linux-Kisten sicherlich auch Probleme mit
einer Windows-Verschlüsselungstrane, haben's nur nicht gemerkt, ja, so wird's sein, ja,
wie gesagt, kengen, kannst hier gucken, ich hab gestern, vorgestern, hier, vorvorgestern,
sogar am Freitag oder so, hab ich hier was gepusht, dass jetzt auch, äh, dass es mit,
dass es nicht mehr ruckelt, dass, äh, Firefox-Support ist, das schneller aufbaut, die Verbindung,
man könnte da wirklich noch ordentliche Anwendungen draus machen, ja, hoffentlich du hast den
Kram aus Startup rausgenommen, nee, Quatsch, das hab ich nicht gemacht, ja, es ist alles
noch drinne hier, guck, Startup, vor allem mit dem besten Namen schlechthin, Loop, klar
kann ich da einfach ne Background-Service draus machen, das ist mir auch klar, dass ich das
theoretisch machen kann, nee, ich mach da kein Background-Service draus, ich mach da
irgendwas, was da einmalig start ist und, also, das muss ja gar nicht integriert sein
mit irgendwie ASP.NET, mal gucken, muss ich mal schauen, vielleicht baue ich da wirklich
was Gescheites draus, irgendwas, was nicht nur ich verwenden kann, sondern was man auch
mal auf GitHub veröffentlichen kann, sodass andere verwenden können, ich hab mir übrigens
letztens was angeguckt, das wollte ich auch mal ausprobieren im Stream, und zwar, kennt
jemand von euch YOLO, YOLO V3, YOLO V4, weiß jemand, was das ist, also ich weiß, was
es ist, nur mal so in den Chat gefragt, V5, ja, also YOLO hat eigentlich nichts mit irgendwelchen
Memes zu tun, YOLO ist Image, Object Detection auf Bildern, also zum Beispiel gibt's da
auch einen C-Sharp-Rapper für, da kann man sowas hier machen, guck, da kann man zum Beispiel
auf Bildern Objekte erkennen lassen und der weiß dann, dass das ein Bird ist oder ein
Duck oder sowas, also der erkennt nicht nur Objekte auf Bildern, so wie es jetzt hier
aussieht, der erkennt auch, was es für Objekte sind, also sprich, der erkennt, das ist ein
Auto und der erkennt, das hier ist eine Ente und sowas, äh, auch Personen, jaja, ein,
ist richtig cool, guck mal, ich hab letztens, letztens ein Video zugesehen von irgendeinem
Inder, den machen wir mal aus, ähm, da gibt's aber ein gutes Beispiel, wie das dann am
Ende aussieht, äh, oder auch nicht, ich hab doch letztens irgendeinen, das sind alles
so Schwachsinn-Tutorials, die kein Mensch braucht, aber ich hab doch ein schönes Bild gesehen,
ne, das mein ich nicht, ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen, wo man dann auch schön erkannt
hat, erkannt hat, was er, was er detectet hat, genau, hier, hier, da hat man's doch gerade
gesehen, so, sieht das dann aus, also sprich, der erkennt, dass das hier quasi Teil, Teil
von, von einer Person ist, das ist, das ist äußerst cool und natürlich muss man das
nicht in der Windows Desktop Anwendung machen, das kann man auch auf irgendeinem Server verwenden,
wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob es auf dem Raspberry Pi läuft, das wäre natürlich
nochmal nice, wenn es auf dem, wenn es, wenn es auf, wenn es da irgendwie ein Arm-Build
oder so für gebe, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob es das gibt, weiß ich, ob es da
ein Arm-Build für gibt, das muss ich mal ausprobieren, Arm, Tiny, Yolo, exzellent,
ja, das probieren wir mal in irgendeinem Stream aus und das könnte ich nämlich, sollte
ich es mal wirklich auf die Reihe kriegen, hier, mal meine Webcam-Überwachungssoftware
so auszubauen, dass man sie auch mal veröffentlichen kann, dann wäre es ja cool, wenn man die
Möglichkeit hätte, dort quasi Object Detection auf dem Keyframe zu machen, also nur auf dem
Keyframe, weil ansonsten müsste man das ganze Video decoden, das will ich nicht, das braucht
so viel CPU-Leistung und läuft nicht mehr auf dem Raspberry Pi, aber man könnte einfach
jeden Keyframe Object Detection machen, das ist dann nicht so wild, ist ja alle, alle
zwei Sekunden mal ein Bild, das klickt auch in den Raspberry Pi für ein paar Kamera-Streams
parallel gut hin, dann könnte man Object Detection machen und dann hätte man einen
riesen Vorteil gegenüber so normaler Bewegungserkennung von der Kamera, weil normale Bewegungserkennung
von der Kamera ist ziemlich doof, wenn du, wenn ihr eine Kamera habt und schaltet Bewegungserkennung
ein und ihr schwenkt die Kamera, sagen wir mal leicht, dann erkennt die Bewegungserkennung
sofort eine Bewegung, ist ja logisch, das Hintergrundbild bewegt sich ja auch, manche
versuchen das zu faken, indem sie die Bewegungserkennung ausschalten, solange der Motor aktiv ist
und sowas, aber im Prinzip ist jegliche Bewegung, wo sich das Bild um so und so viele Pixel
oder was auch immer ändert, in einem gewissen Bereich erkennt die Bewegungsmeldung, ja also
da wackelt ein Baum im Hintergrund, Bewegungsmeldung schlägt an und mit Object Detection auf einem
Kamerabild ist das Ganze natürlich viel cooler, denn da kannst du zum Beispiel erkennen, ah,
da ist gerade höchstwahrscheinlich eine Person durch Hoftor gegangen, jetzt löse ich mal
die Bewegungsmeldung aus, mal gucken, ob das gut funktioniert, das werden wir mal ausprobieren.
Was richtig cool wäre, wenn es das ganze als fertigen Docker-Container gäbe, einfach
mit einer Rest-AP, wo ich ein Bild hinschicken kann und bekomme dann die Koordinaten zurück,
das wäre am allerbesten, da muss ich selbst nichts programmieren dafür, aber mal gucken,
das probieren wir mal in einem Stream aus in nächster Zeit, so, mal schauen wir uns,
wo wir gerade beim Thema Raspberry Pi sind, das wollte ich mir schon mal angucken, der
Typ hat versucht auf den Raspberry Pi eine Vierfach Gigabit Netzwerkkarte dran zu kriegen.
Ja, gut, mehr wird der Raspberry Pi Inter nicht hergeben.
Ey, wo wir gerade bei Werbung von Twitch sind, ne, wisst ihr was ich neuerdings auf Reddit
immer für ne Werbung bekomme, also Twitch hab ich ja keine Werbung, auf Reddit bekomm
ich, auf Reddit, wohlgemerkt, auf Reddit, nicht auf Twitch, bekomm ich Kronk-Werbung,
hat das noch jemand?
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich Kronk-Werbung auf Reddit bekomme, das passt so überhaupt nicht
zusammen, okay, ich bin nicht der einzige, also, hä, also erstens, Twitch-Werbung auf
Reddit ist schon mal irgendwie ziemlich Paynes-Champ, ja, ja, also Twitch, die benutzen Kronk dafür,
ja zum Glück benutzen sie wenigstens noch einen dafür, wo ich sagen würde, den kann
man auch, kann man auch mal Leuten empfehlen, okay, ich guck, ich hab noch nie wirklich
Kronk geguckt, aber das ist jemand, der ist wenigstens nicht so übelst zum Fremdschämen
wie manch andere Sachen, da kann man wenigstens Werbung dafür machen, aber trotzdem, warum
ist es Twitch, warum gibt's Kronk-Werbung für Twitch auf Reddit?
Ja, das ist klar, dass Kronk nicht selbst Werbung macht, das hab ich schon kapiert,
ich bin ja nicht komplett Low-Brain, so, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben, ja, manchen
auf Reddit ist da, ja, das wundert mich nix, dass also, dass manchen Leuten auf Reddit,
was nicht klar ist, und auf Twitter und auf Facebook und auf Instagram und auf Snapchat
und so, dass da viele Leute Sachen, die offensichtlich sind, nicht klar sind, das ist mir klar,
weil die meisten Leute sind einfach nur doof, die kapieren einfach gar nix, egal wie offensichtlich
du manchmal nen Witz machst, die Leute checken's einfach nicht, die sind einfach nicht, das
Hirn von den Leuten ist einfach nicht empfänglich für solche Arten von Sätzen, hey, kommt mir
bekannt vor, ich glaub, das ist die gleiche, die ich in meiner alten Kiste drin hat hier,
IGB, äh, könnte man machen, ist eigentlich gar
keine so schlechte Idee, leistungsmäßig ist okay für was kleines, ich wär nie auf
die Idee gekommen, aus dem Raspberry Pi nen Router zu machen, geht ja auch nicht ordentlich,
außer mit ganz viel USB zu Netzwerk, was auch kacke ist, besser wahrscheinlich wie
ne Mast rauszubauen, wobei man halt dazusagen muss, man kann sich einfach nen MikroTik-Router
holen und man muss gar nix selbst bauen, denn der Vorteil wäre, dass man selbst was drauf
machen kann, dass du NLPFSense installieren kannst, Open VRT, RouterOS, was auch immer,
wenn man das will, ja übrigens, also dieses neue Computer, also das eigentliche Computer,
also dieses Computer, das hat jetzt als allererster Raspberry Pi, hat es jetzt ne Möglichkeit,
PCI Express anzubinden.
Das geht, das geht, aber das würd ich auch nicht machen, weil dann muss ich ja mein PCI
Express-Slot aufdrehmeln.
Was kosten sowas, sowas brauch ich, sowas, sowas brauch ich, Moment, sowas brauch ich,
das ist aber die, das ist die Chinesen-Variante, die suckt bestimmt, oh nein, jetzt hab ich
schon wieder gesagt, dass die Chinesen schlechte Sachen bauen, jetzt, jetzt bin ich wieder
übelst racist, frag mal Twitter, nicht schon wieder, nicht schon wieder, Twitter hat mich
ja das, oh das sieht, oh das sieht, oh das sieht gut aus, das Ding hier, hochqualitative,
hochqualitative Arbeit, was zum Geil, VTF, was ist denn das, okay, okay, um jetzt, dass
mir keiner vorwerfen kann, ich würde da einseitig immer sagen, dass die Chinesen so komische
Sachen bauen, das war bestimmt kein Chinese, das war bestimmt ein Chilene in China, der
dieses Ding gebaut hat, wir müssen ja divers sein, ich nehm jetzt einfach jedes Mal, wenn
ich sagen würde Chinese, nehm ich jetzt irgendeine andere Nationalität, dann kann sich keiner
angepisst fühlen.
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst, Alter, das sieht, das sieht ja, MonkaS, was ist denn
das für Zeug, das ist irgendein Miner-Equipment, dass du an PC-Express einfach mehrere Grafikkarten
anschließen kannst, aber das sieht alles ziemlich, ziemlich fail aus, oder, Alter, was ist das
denn, das sieht aus, als hätte das irgendwie in seiner Kellerwerkstatt zusammengeklebt
und tape drüber gebappt, sowas kann man doch nicht verkaufen, soll die mich komplett,
sowas kann man doch nicht verkaufen, schon gar nicht für 11 Euro, was zum Geil ist das
hier, das ist irgendein Keller-Bastel-Ding, was ich selbst hätte bauen können, okay,
wo gibt's denn einen ordentlichen Adapter, ich seh hier nix, was das erste ist, das hier
meinste, ja, okay, das sieht schon halbwegs vernünftig aus, was das blaue, sowas hier,
guck mal, was seh, das was er hier hat, sieht viel besser aus, finde ich, guck mal, das
was er hier hat, sieht viel qualitativ besser aus, guck mal, das sieht so richtig, so richtig
ordentlich zusammengemacht aus, und es rutscht auch nicht raus wie ein USB-Kabel, ich finde
das gar nicht, wo gibt's denn sowas, bei Ebay, gibt sowas nicht bei normalen Läden zu kaufen,
guck mal, hier neben geht schon der Kleber ab, ne, what, Alter, es wird ja immer, es
wird ja immer schlimmer, wenn ein Schrumpfschlauch da nicht mal geschrumpft ist oben drüber,
was ist denn, das sieht aus, als hätte ich das hier nebenbei zusammengelötet, während
ich irgendwie Let's Play gucke oder so, nein, während ich selbst striebe und nebenbei was
zusammengelötet hab, so sieht das aus, Aliexpress, was haben die Chinesen zu bieten, PCI-Express,
1216, das ist ja das gleiche Kram wieder, nur, guck mal, die haben, die haben Upgraded
jetzt, jetzt ohne Klebeband, ne, ne, mit schwarzem Klebeband, mit Zulul-Klebeband, ne, oje, schon
wieder Monkathos hier, das ist für meiner, ja, aber das sieht aus, als hält das keine
zwei Monate, hier guck mal, sowas hat der da, sowas hat der doch, sowas da, ok, das
sieht, das sieht, das sieht schon besser aus, das, das sieht schon besser aus, ok, das sieht
so aus, als fällt es nicht sofort auseinander, das kann man sich, das kann man sich geben,
ok, das sieht, das sieht, das sieht ok aus, das sieht echt in Ordnung aus, guck mal, hier
gibt's, hier gibt's sogar mit extra Stromanschluss, falls man da Big Brain GPU rein machen will
oder so, gibt's das Ganze jetzt vielleicht auch noch nicht aus China, sondern woanders
her, oder suchen wir mal danach, ne, ja, dann muss AliExpress bestellen, so, für 1,14 Euro
interessant, er hat's verlinkt, echt, cool, ja, Amazon.com, Amazon.com, da kann ich nix
bestellen und das ist genau das gleiche, was der bei Amazon.com hat, sowas, Caseking, das
heißt, wir kaufen beim Bauer, war der Bauer nicht bei Caseking? Ach, was muss ich denn
da suchen? Ihh, die haben ja auch diesen gleichen hässlichen Krempel, warum verkaufen die alle
diese selbst im Keller zusammengelötete Crap Zeug? Weil's funst, ja, zwei Monate lang,
und es ist auseinandergefallen, schau mal, Artikel Nummer 99, ok, ok, mach ich, jetzt
kommt wahrscheinlich irgendein Anime-Kissen oder sowas, was haben wir hier, EGX Upgrade,
dann mal Pizzi, ah ja, ok, das sieht, das sieht schon ein bissl besser aus, ne, ich bestell
mir mal bei AliExpress, easy, erstens nicht lieber, aber ich bestell mir mal bei AliExpress
5 Stück, 3 Stück, 3 Stück reichen, ihr wisst ja, nie einzeln kaufen bei AliExpress, erstens
vielleicht mal was kaputt, und zweitens macht man auch schnell was kaputt, 3 Stück, Kost,
haben wir noch andere Shipping, ah, 81 Euro mit DHL, excellent, das erscheint mir nach
einer attraktiven Versandmöglichkeit, so, AliExpress Standard Shipping, kostet 30 Euro
am Ende, das ist ok, haben die eigentlich coole ZigBee Door Sensors hier, oh, das ist
aber günstig, 339, eh, die Cokomodots sind wieder am Start, 339, das ist massiv billig,
bei AliExpress geht das, lass mal, geht das, doch, das geht mit Paypal, es kommt aber auf
den Shop an, AliExpress ist ja eigentlich nur ein Marketplace, ein großer, aber nicht
nach Germany, wohin kann man liefern lassen, nach Afghanistan vielleicht, nein, Arland,
was, was, was für Dinge, Arland Islands, ah, das ist irgendwas zwischen Schweden und
Finnland, alles klar, ne, geht nicht, ok, aber das ist scheiß billig, alter, 339, da würde
ich mir gleich mal ein 20er Pack bestellen, ZigBee Heizkörper Thermostat Tipps, ne, immer
noch nicht, ich kann dir nur das zeigen, was ich habe, ich kann dir nur zeigen, was ich
habe, aber, ich bin da immer noch, also ich hab das hier, aber nicht kaufen für den Preis,
das ist nicht zu teuer, ne, das funktioniert auch gut, aber so hundertprozentig glücklich
bin ich mit dem Ding nicht, das ist ok, aber ein bisschen hochwertiger gebaut könnte sein,
was ich gut finde ist, dass man dran drehen kann, ob das mit Home Assistant eingebauten
geht, weiß ich nicht, verwende ich nicht, übrigens, dieses Ding, ob da jetzt Revolt
oder Essentials oder sonst was dran steht ist egal, das ist alles das gleiche unter der
Haube, ich mach das mit ZigBee 2 MQTT und damit funktioniert's wunderbar, so, aber das
ist echt billig, guck mal, wenn was aus China teurer ist hier, haben wir hier 4 Stück für
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 5, 8, 10, 8, 7, ok, macht keinen großen Unterschied,
na egal, ich bestell jetzt nichts, den hab ich mir aber mal hier in Warenkorb reingelegt,
das andere, das kann man nicht zu genug von haben von solchen Adaptern, also Adapter
auf Adapter, Adapter an sich kann man nicht genug haben, irgendwann braucht man mal jeden
Adapter, zahlst du da Zoll, es kommt drauf an, wie gut der Versender das macht, also
ich muss bei Aliexpress glaube ich bisher noch nie Zoll bezahlen, ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher, wo ich jedes Mal Zoll bezahlen muss ist, wenn ich was aus den USA bestelle, die
kriegen das immer nicht gebacken, 30 Euro, nee, das ist mir zu teuer dann, bei Aliexpress
kostet es 9, Cuddy machst du auch über Cuddyfile, ja, mach ich, ja, Cuddy v2 mittlerweile sogar,
ok, also wir gucken jetzt erstmal das Video, exzellent, es sieht schon irgendwie ein bisschen
fail aus, das nächste Problem dürfte sein, verwendest du auf Aliexpress Gutscheincodes,
nur wenn sie es mir in your face reindrücken, die Gutscheincodes, Gutscheincodes bei Aliexpress
lohnen sich meistens nicht, das ist dann so 73 Cent und solche komischen Dinger, das
macht es meistens nicht fett, das nächste Problem ist, wenn man wirklich sowas bauen
will, in welches Gehäuse machst du das rein, das passt ja echt nirgendswo rein, oder was
ist das für ein Formfaktor, hat das irgendeinen sinnvollen, Leute, ist das irgendein sinnvoller
Formfaktor, der irgendwo reinpasst? Case, Banggood, gibts wieder was, bei Banggood,
Moment, das ist das alte, ja man kann es 3D drucken, aber da muss ein eigenes Gehäuse
sein, mit passendem Ausgang für die Netzwerkkarte, das könnte man machen, ja aber bis ich in
irgendeinem 3D Programm das designt habe, sodass die Netzwerkkarte mit reinpasst, habe
ich besser was gekauft, gibt es bestimmt schon, na das glaube ich nicht, dass es auf Thingiverse
ein Compute Module Gehäuse gibt, mit passenden Sachen für eine Netzwerkkarte, also auf Thingiverse
gibt es viel, aber dafür glaube ich nicht, Moment, der hat versucht eine Grafikkarte zum
Laufen zu bekommen, was ist Bar, also ich kenne aus Call of Duty 5 noch eine Bar, das
ist übelst Pains Champ, Boomerwitz jetzt gewesen, aus Call of Duty 5 noch eine Bar,
was für eine, was hat Bar bei PCI Express zu bedeuten, ist das Attrace, Binary Attrace,
Byte Attrace, Register, ich habe keine Ahnung was Bar ist, Bar, what, what, Base Attrace
Register, hey ich war gar nicht so schlecht, müsst ihr zugeben, von wo ich geraten habe,
ich war aber irgendwie was, irgendetwas mit Register war ich schon mal, Real Chicken schreibt,
ich habs mal geschafft mit C++, dass die Konsole Hello World ausgibt, ich glaube jetzt bin
ich ein Hacker, ne, allein schon weil es C++ ist, bist du der richtige Hacker man, C++,
wenn du eine schwierige Aufgabe hast, dies zu lösen gilt, und du machst den C++, das
macht es auch mal doppelt so schwer, schon mal Raspberry Pad, die Netzwerkkarte schon
mal nicht erkannt.
Ich habe die Netzwerke von Lowe, ETH0, die Internet-Interface auf der Pi, und WLAN0, die Wifi-Interface.
Also was ich, mal gucken was er macht, also was ich machen würde ist, wenn ich, wenn
ich denken würde, dass kein Treiber, ich würde erstmal gucken wie das Treibermodul heißt,
ich gehe mal davon aus, das ist IGB, weil IGB ist der Standard Internet-Netzwerk Treiber
unter Linux, IGB und IGBE, IGBE oder IGBX, ich glaube IGBE ist für 10G und IGB ist für
Gigabit-Netzwerkkarten, so, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich die Kernelsachen klonen und
einen neuen Kernel bilden mit den Modulen drinnen, oder gucken ob man die als Module
bauen kann oder sowas, schwierig zu sagen, müssen wir mal schauen, aber wahrscheinlich
dürfte es die sogar schon fertig irgendwo geben, weil gerade Internet-Netzwerkkarten-Module
für Arm dürfte es, dürfte es wahrscheinlich schon irgendwo geben, oh, was jetzt los, Basti
Baron 5 Abos exquisite gift, nice, dankeschön, und zwar wer, wer kriegt dann was, Memory
Man kriegt was, exellent, Kussi, Reed, Spatze Digger, alles klar, und Valentin, ja dankeschön
für die ganzen gegifteten Subs, huge, massive, IIQ Subs, Door Sensor von Aquara ist jetzt
auch für 13 Euro bei Amazon drin, echt, schick mal Link, Blitz, aber bestimmt mit China-Versand
von 5 Wochen, ja genau, sowas in der Richtung hätt ich auch mal, IGB muss, also IGB heißt
das, ich geh mal davon aus, dass es IGB als Treiber ist, what the fuck, der Link ist aber
auch Big Brain Link, oh, das ist sogar relativ günstig, das ist relativ günstig, ich mein
bei Aliexpress kriegste es ein bisschen billiger, Chat, das Angebot ist ganz gut, wenn man es
nicht bei Aliexpress oder Banggood kaufen will, das geht, bei Banggood ist ein bisschen, also
wenn du es in China bestellst, dann kriegste, kriegste die Sache mit Glück um die 10 Euro
vielleicht, ja, guck mal was es auf Banggood kostet, Banggood hat übrigens eh den besten
Plattform Namen schlechthin, also auf Banggood ist es eine ganze Ecke günstiger, vielleicht
wenn man noch hingeht und kauft sich, aus Tschechien, Spanien, ne also wenn man es aus
China bestellt, da kriegt man es für, also guck mal da kriegste 10 Stück oder kriegste
ein, was ist denn das hier, Euro, 9, also das ist tatsächlich deutlich günstiger, lohnt
sich natürlich nur, wenn man mehr kauft, weil 3 Euro versandt, aber 3 Euro versandt
natürlich vollkommen in Ordnung, ich bin geneigt, ich bin geneigt, was kostet mich
das dann auf Euro, was kostet mich das dann auf, ach ne Delete, was kostet mich das dann
109 Dollar inklusive Versand, ne, ohne Versand, aber das fällt jetzt auch nicht mehr groß
ins Gewicht, 94 Euro, so und hier würde ich halt trotzdem für 10 Stück, würde ich halt
13 und auch nicht mal 30 mal 10, hier würde ich halt 130 bezahlen, also im Prinzip könnte
ich da so 20 Euro ungefähr sparen, ob es ja, ob man, ja ob das, aber es ist echt okay,
also wenn man die Sachen in Deutschland kaufen will, ist der Preis ganz in Ordnung hiervon,
ich überleg grad, ob ich mir nicht, ob ich mir nicht tatsächlich noch mal irgendwie
ein 5er Pack oder so kaufe, einfach zum ausprobieren, wobei ne, ich hab nen 3er Pack jetzt erst
bestellt, das reicht, lass ich, aber es lohnt sich echt, also wer ZigBee Sachen daheim
hat und noch nen Fenster Türsensor braucht, also und es halt in Deutschland bestellen
will, dass er das nen Tag später bekommt, ist das aktuelle Angebot hier bei Amazon
ist wirklich nicht verkehrt, 12 Euro kann man machen, ach man kann, man kann, man darf
nur einen bestellen oder was, ja Moment, das sackt ja, mit einem kommst ja nicht weit,
ja das einen lohnt sich ja nicht, man kann wirklich nur einen bestellen, ja das ist ja
Müll, ne dann lohnt sich das nicht, Menge 1, mit 1, gut vielleicht wenn man es ausprobieren
will, aber mit nur einem kommt man ja nicht weit, ich mein wer hat nur eine Fenster oder
nur eine Tür, ne ne, das Aquara Cube, was macht der denn, ich hab Schalter, das reicht,
du hast nur ein Fenster, feelsbadman, für was ist der Aquara Cube, für was ist das Ding,
was macht man damit, den dreht man rum oder was und dann macht der Dinger, oder wie oder
was ich checks nicht, ok da geht null draus hervor was das Ding macht, hand gestures, press,
shake, tap, rotate, tilt, tilt, achso das ist quasi so ne Art Knopf, aber die Idee ist
nicht schlecht, das gefällt mir, muss ich sagen, die Idee gefällt mir, komm ich hau
mir mal einen Einkaufswagen, das schadet nix, so excellent, Twitch, Chat ich hab euch irgendwie
grad zugemacht, so jetzt hab ich euch wieder auf, das Stockbild, so ok schauen wir mal
weiter, haben wir die wichtigen Sachen, haben wir, also falls ich irgendwas übersehen hab,
oh ich kacke nur, jetzt hab ich den Chat wirklich zugemacht, null, ok gucken wir mal weiter,
so wo sind wir stehen geblieben, Gigabit Ethernet für den Raspberry Pi, was ist denn das, ich
hab euch weggeswiped Chat, oh ok vielleicht n bisschen großes Driverpack, ok, ok, ok,
wie kommt man da an?
Wir haben nochendo ca.
!]
erie und wie reasoniert jetzt der
Which makes it a little more annoying because I can't just download the file in the command line using wget
Anyways, I downloaded it through chromium and then expanded the archive with tar xzf
Then I went into the source directory and ran make install like the instructions told me to do
The install process said it could have been double you get so I went cac w verwendet zum download
Wir alles gut gewesen them with sudo apt install raspberry pi kernel headers
Then I ran make install again this time. It's spent some time doing the build but eventually the build aired out
And I saw this error about an implicit
Alter z
Ich kann ich nicht mehr flayen das ist noch nicht mal z plus plus
Funktion ist digit
Undaunted I did what every super advanced computer scientist does when faced with adversity and
copied and pasted the error message into Google or actually duck duck go in my case and
And luck was with me because the first result mentioned that the problem was a missing include of the sea
Das ist halt so typisches linux gebastel damit du den treiber für eine interne netzwerk karte zum laufen kriegst
musste erst mal den source code mit in nem include patchen dass der netzwerk treiber kompiliert dass dann der netzwerk hat verwendet kannst
Normalerweise ist kein problem
Weil interne netzwerk treiber sind in jedem linux korn dabei die mussten selbstverständlich nicht selbst kompilieren
Aber dass das raspian hat natürlich kein oder das raspberry pi os wie es jetzt heißt hat keine interne netzwerk
Karten treiber dabei für pci express weil der raspberry pi normalerweise kein pci express hat
Oder bis jetzt also das compute model 4 mit diesem komischen board ist ja das erste der aller allererste raspberry pi
Der pci express hat das heißt die haben den ganzen kram einfach noch nicht included ich könnte mir vorstellen dass es das demnächst geben wird
Arme mit diesem neuen Wissen habe ich das file editiert, welches die Errung gebrochen hat, welches namens igb-underscore-main.c
Und ich habe eine extra include linke mit linux-slash-ctype.h
Diesmal, als ich den make install gemacht habe, sah es gut aus, aber am Ende, als es versuchte, Dinge in einem Ort zu kopieren, habe ich eine Errung der Permissionen
Also habe ich den xkcd-advice folgt und habe sudo gesagt, dass ich einen install mache und diesmal ist es fertig
So was kannst du ja auch nicht als normaler user machen, das ist normal
whatsoever thanks sudo
Ich könnte modprobe benutzen, um den neuen kernel-modul sofort zu erledigen, aber ich habe die pi ausgebildet und meine Fingern krossiert
Und nach einem erledigen war ich überrascht und sehr glücklich, alle vier interfaces zu sehen, als ich ip-link-show
Also die nächste stelle, die mir viel mehr interessant ist, ist zu sehen
Also ich glaube nicht, dass der 5x gigabit darüber kriegt, eigentlich sind es ja 6x gigabit, nee 5x gigabit, 4x von der Netzwerkkarte
und
Ja, 4x von der Netzwerkkarte und 5x on-board
I can support all 5 gigabit ethernet interfaces at full speed at the same time
Das glaube ich nicht, dass das klappt
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, vielleicht 2-3, also er hat es ja schon gesagt am Anfang
Er hat es ja am Anfang schon gesagt, 2-3 gigabit vielleicht, da reicht die interne Anbindung beim raspberry pi garantiert nicht aus, um wirklich
5 5 gigabit, ich meine man darf nicht vergessen, 5 gigabits sind
625 megabit die sekunde das ist ganz schön viel
Das ist das was man über so eine satan, über eine gute satan ssd maximal drüberkriegt
Weiß gar nicht was maximum satan ist aktuell
Der guckt so streng
Wo habe ich das video? Ah ich bin kaknoob, wo habe ich das video? Leute wo ist das video?
KAKNOOB, wo habe ich das video? Leute wo ist das?
He doesn't know
The built-in ethernet controller at around 940 megabit
So I expect I'll get at least that much out of the four new interfaces individually
Im Leben nicht
The real question is how much bandwidth can I get out of all five interfaces at the same time?
But I ran into a problem
My home network is only a one gigabit network and even if I said
Zeit zum upgraden würde ich sagen
Sollte sich jetzt erstmal einen ordentlichen mikrotik switch kaufen
Mit gigabit anbindung dann kauft er sich noch
Den nass mit mit mit 10g anbindung also der soll sich in 10g switch kaufen kauft sich nass mit 10 gigabit anbindung und macht
Ssd rate null und dann kann das testen
Set up five computers to pump data to the pie as fast as possible using the iperf network benchmarking tool
The network will only put through a maximum. Ich hatte noch nie dieses compute module
Ich wusste bis eben gar nicht dass es das doch ich wusste dass es das gibt aber ich wusste nicht dass es für die pie 4 schon
eins gibt so i had to get a little bit creative i had my home network and my macbook pro
Und das muss das erste mit pc express an weil die alten hatten definitiv kein pc express
I can use for one of the interfaces, but I needed to have four more completely separate computers to talk with the compute module with
Their own full gigabit interfaces, so I thought for computers, and they need to all have gigabit network interfaces
Where could I find four computers to do this and then I remembered I have a raspberry pie
Was kann er einfach mehr raspberry pies anschließen. Oh das ist das ist was das sind mal cute cute netzwerk kabel oder
Die sind so die sind so
So klein und handlich irgendwie
Für pie 4s und wenn ich sie alle an einen der porten auf dem intel card verbinden würde
Ich hätte meine fünf voll gigabit connectionen und ich könnte den test machen
Also ich habe den drambul football geöffnet, eröffnete ihn, halte den stack von pie aus, und dann habe ich gemerkt
Ich hätte ein paar usb-c charger anbauen müssen. Was hat er denn da für eine Riesentasche?
Wozu hat er so einen riesen koffer für dieses raspberry pie rack?
Kabel weil ich normalerweise all diese pies durch meinen entscheidend langen 1 gigabit poe-switch
Und ich kann keine power über die direkte ethernet connection zwischen dem intel card und den pies
Also ich habe ein paar usb-c charger anbaut,
reflasht die pie 4s zu jedem pie und sie alle in den intel card verbinden
Um es zu machen, damit ich die pies und ihre netzwerken konfigurieren kann, setze ich sie auf, damit ihre wireless interface
verbunden ist mit meinem home wifi netzwerk
So kann ich sie verbinden und sie kontrollieren. Das ist nicht verkehrt. Ja an diesem point. Ich kann sehen, dass die wirelinks hoch sind
Aber sie haben sich die IP-addressen selbst verwendet, also konnte ich keine Daten transferieren
Wenn du so einen koffer am hauptbahnhof stehen lässt, kommt das Sondereinsatzkommando
Ramble pies und das Computermodul
Also musste ich statische IP-addressen für alle pies und alle interfaces setzten
Ich werde nicht in die IP und das Netzwerken in diesem Video tiefdrehen. Und um ehrlich zu sein, denke ich, das Netzwerken ist halb Voodoo-Magie
Ich selbst, aber wenn du alle Details wollen, wie ich drei privaten IP-Ranges und zwei Test-IP-Ranges verwendet habe, schau auf die GitHub-Issue, die in der Deskription in diesem Video verlinkt ist
Wozu? Der kann eben alle gleiche IP-Adress-Ranges verwendet haben
Der kann dem Ding einfach, keine Ahnung
Den Klassiker 1221681.1 1221681.2 geben, macht doch für seinen IP-Adress-Ranges überhaupt keinen Unterschied
Ich habe die Etsy-DHCP-CD-Konfig-File auf den Pies und auf dem Computermodul 4 aufgedeckt und statische IP-Adressen getestet, die alles zusammenmappen
Dann installierte ich IPerf auf alle Pies, um die Bandweite zu messen
Finally, once I could confirm each individual Pi could ping the CM4 through its unique network interface, I ran IPerf in server mode five times on the compute module, one for each interface, and then I simultaneously ran IPerf on each of the Pies on my Mac, one instance connecting to each interface
And the result was pretty good, but not quite as good as I hoped
In total, with five independent gigabit networks. Ja, das dachte ich mir. Ich meine, er hat es am Anfang ja schon gesagt, aber dass der wirklich da quasi 620 MB durchklickt, hätte ich nicht gedacht
Das ist jetzt ungefähr die Hälfte. Ah, nicht, bisschen, bisschen, bisschen, bisschen mehr als die Hälfte
Ähm, keine Ahnung, das sind so, was sind das, so 400 MB oder so
Deshalb habe ich aber schon gedacht, dass das nicht komplett durchpasst
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, was das für ein PCI-Express ist, ehrlich gesagt, das ist zwei
PCI-Express zwei, das ist drei, das ist vier, das ist fünf
Ja, 3G ist nicht schlecht
Die Frage, wofür man sowas braucht, die Frage stellt sich nicht, die Frage ist, ob man sowas machen kann
Ich hoffe, man sowas braucht. Und ob man sowas braucht, ich finde die Anwendung hier, die Idee gar nicht mal so verkehrt
Wenn man sich wirklich mal so in eine PF-Sense-Box bauen will oder so, ist das gar nicht so verkehrt, finde ich
Das wird kein Ultra-High-Performance-Router werden hier, ja
Zumal der ja auch alles in Software mehr oder weniger machen muss
Aber das ist nicht verkehrt, es gibt nicht so viele gute Boards und, wobei ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht weiß
Gibt es ein Arm-Bild von PF-Sense?
Gibt es ein Arm-Bild für...
Nur für deren offizielle Hardware, ok
Ah super, nein, dann bringt es nichts
Opsense, Pi, haben die was?
Work-in-Progress, Porting, tja
Ich meine, man kann Open-WRT und sowas installieren, wobei es ja nicht mehr, es heißt ja nicht mal Open-WRT, es heißt jetzt irgendwie Lede oder sowas
Lede-WRT
Lede ist es jetzt ja, also es ist immer noch Open-WRT, aber es ist Lede
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass PCI-Express einfach nicht mehr hergibt
Ich meine, es ist einfach PCI-Express und je nachdem, was das für eine Version ist, macht das auch nicht so viel
Wie heißen diese Boards, was der da hat?
Wie heißen dieses Board? Pi, Computemodel, Board, Board, PCI-Express, wie heißen diese Dinger?
IO-Board, genau
Pi, Four, Computemodel, IO-Board
Die da, genau, sowas, was ist denn da für ein PCI-Express drauf?
Was ist denn das für einer?
PCI
GAN 2, ok, da passt eh nicht mehr drüber
War da irgendwo eine Beschreibung von?
Ja
Jaja, ist ja gut, jetzt übertreibt's mal nicht Wikipedia
Übertreibt's mal nicht, hier
So, und davon muss man ja jetzt noch abziehen
Davon muss man ja irgendwie noch 20% abziehen, dass man auf die realistische Sache kommt
Hä?
Das erscheint mir ein bisschen wenig, ehrlich gesagt
0,5G
Will ich jetzt, check ich's bloß nicht?
Ist denn das wirklich bloß 0,5G die Sekunde, die ich da drüber krieg?
Das ist gar nicht so, gar nicht, gar nicht wirklich
Nee, das sind mehr
Ich bin verwirrt
Das sind, das sind vier, das sind, das sind
Ach Gigabyte, ja, ok, ja, ja, ja, ja, ok
Äh, jetzt, jetzt ergibt das denn, ok
Dann rächen wir das mal um
So, also vier Gigabit, ja, das passt doch
Das kommt, das kommt doch hin
Also maximal kann man 500 MP übertragen
Aber 20% ungefähr gehen weg bei PCI Express für Encoding und Gedöns
Da kommt das ziemlich gut hin, was der da gemessen hat
Das kommt ziemlich gut hin mit seinen 3, noch was Gigabit
Du kannst maximal, du kannst maximal, maximal vier Gigabit machen
Davon musst du 20% abziehen für Encoding, Overhead und Gedöns, PCI Express
Ähm, das kommt hin, mehr wird er da nicht drüber kriegen
Und das hat nichts mit dem Raspberry Pi Netzwerk Stack zu tun
Das ist weil über PCI Express ein, Gen 2 einfach schlicht und ergreifend nicht mehr drüber geht
Nein, neuen PCI Express, besseren PCI Express, mehr geht nicht
PFSense wird, haben wir ja gerade nachgeguckt, PFSense läuft nicht
Technos, ja
Ja gut, das ist, das ist abartig, ne
Also das wird ja auch keiner machen, der noch irgendwie bei Verstand ist
Ganz ehrlich, das einfachste ist tatsächlich, sich einen fertigen Router zu kaufen
Irgendeine Mikrotikkiste oder meinetwegen auch eine UniFi-Kiste oder
Manche schwören auf irgendwelche ausgemusterten Cisco-Switch-Kram, die auch ein bisschen
Routing-Gedöns machen können, wobei man sagen muss, dass die
Äh, ganzen Switch, also die 24-Port-Dinger
Die können ja zum größten Teil auch Layer 3 Geschichten machen
Also die können auch Sachen routen, aber das ist komplett in CPU und nicht sonderlich schnell
Also für ein Rechner und so kein Problem, aber wenn da mehrere Rechner, mehrere Clients im Netz sind
Und die alle ein bisschen Traffic machen, dann kommt
So die 0815-Switch-Hardware mit Routing schon ziemlich schnell an ihre Grenzen
Zumal, zumal man auch dazu sagen muss
Ich, ich, ich sag's ja immer wieder
Und da hatte ich auch schon, da hatte ich auch schon Riesen-Diskussionen mit irgendwelchen Netzwerk-Leuten bei uns
Es gibt keinen Layer 3-Switch
Switch hat mit Layer 3 nichts zu tun
Es gibt Geräte, Multifunktionsgeräte, die als Switch verkauft werden
Die unter anderem auch ein bisschen Routing-Funktionalität drinne haben
Aber das eigentliche Switch ist, ist einzig und allein Layer 2
Das hat nichts mit irgendwelchen Routen oder sonst was zu tun
Nur weil die Hersteller diese Geräte verkaufen unter dem Namen
Muss das noch lange nicht stimmen
Richtig Taze, genau, ein Multifunktionsgerät
Ja, so sieht's aus
Bald gibt's eh Machine Learning Router, genau
Da brauchst du dann Machine Learning Router
Da brauchst du dann keine Routing-Tabelle mehr
Der lernt nach ein paar Minuten, wo welches Paket hin soll
Big Brain Router
Im Comment stand, dass er nicht die PCI-Lanes ausreizt
Okay, hab ich jetzt gar nicht geguckt
Wo stand das hier in den Comments?
Doch, macht er, macht er
Also PCI-Express ist, viel mehr geht da drüber nicht
Der macht maximal 4 Gigabit
So, dann kommt Encoding-Overhead drüber
Mehr geht nicht, der wird da nicht viel mehr drüber kriegen
Wir haben ja gerade in der Speck nachgeguckt
Was hast du schon mal, das LG Wing
Was ist denn das, kenn ich nicht, LG Wing
Ist das ein Handy oder so?
Android-based Fablet
Fablet, beste Gerätekategorie überhaupt
Fablets, also keine Fablets, sondern Fablets
Also nicht Salami-Tablets
So, was?
Was bin ich sehend?
What the fuck?
Ist das hier irgendwie was zum Teufel austreiben oder?
Das ist für, das ist für Gläubige, da kannst du immer so mit so einem Kreuz-Handy rumlaufen
Es sieht, ähm, ja
Es sieht gewöhnungsbedürftig aus
Ich kann dazu nichts sagen, ich hab mir das, ich seh das jetzt das erste Mal
Wow, Otto
Dass es die noch gibt
Und wie klappt man das?
Wie klappt man das? Hier ist es ein Gerät und hier sind es zwei
Kann man das irgendwie nahtlos auseinander klappen?
Wir gucken uns dann mal kurz ein Video zu haben, ich bin echt gespannt, wie das ausschaut
So
Wow, MonkaS
Das sieht ja aus, als geht das Scharnier kaputt nach dreimal klappen
Oh
Ist cool, was bitte nicht die Videos von ihm, ich kenn den nicht, keine Ahnung
Welche Videos denn dann?
Was, Jerry, von wem?
Von wem habe ich noch nie gehört?
Jerry, Rick, everything
Ach der Typ ist das doch, das haben wir sogar schon mal was geguckt von ihm
Exzellent
Alter mach nicht so nen Krach
Ich mein cool ist es, cool ist es, ich bin mir nicht sicher wie praktikabel das ist, aber cool ist es
Die Frage ist wie lang das hält, ne
Und wisst ihr was das Problem ist an Android Geräten?
Wenn das Ding sich nicht verkauft, wird es dafür nicht ein Firmware Update geben
Und das ist so besonders, wo ich konnte mir vorstellen, da ist mit Custom Firmware Update auch nicht so, mit Custom Firmware auch nicht so viel
Es fühlt sich cool an wie slided
Das erste was passiert, wenn das Ding dir mal aus der Hose fällt, ist aufswifeln und swingen und abbrechen
Ja
Ja, aber eigentlich ziemlich useless, ne
Weil ansonsten drückst du einmal drauf, stellst es ein, es ist ja nicht so als machst du das laufend, während du das Video guckst
Okay, das wirkt echt übelst futuristisch
Es wirkt echt futuristisch, aber das sieht sehr anfällig aus, dass es kaputt geht
Das sieht aus, als habe ich drei Geräte aufeinander liegen gerade, als habe ich mein Smartphone hingelegt, da drüber habe ich ein Tablet gelegt und da unten drunter liegt noch irgendwas anderes
Das Sebaro ist da, cute Mod persönlich
Ach Sebaro, wann willst du denn das Zeug umziehen eigentlich?
Ups
So ein Blitzding, aus beiden Flecken, ja so sieht es wirklich aus
Warum ist da ein Hund drauf?
Ach, das soll bedeuten, dass man es nicht an Hund verfüttern darf? Ja gut, bei den Amis musst du das machen, das ist typische Freedom Aktion
Ist ja klar, aber was sonst? Man könnte sich Gedanken darüber machen, warum man so dumm war und hat seinem Hund einen Akku verfüttert, aber besser ist man verklagt den Akkuhersteller
So ein Blitzding, aus beiden Flecken, aus beiden Flecken, ja so sieht es wirklich aus
Also seit Apple angefangen hat mit 5 Millionen Kameras in Handys, müssen das alle anderen auch machen, hat das neue iPhone nicht mittlerweile sogar 4 Kameras?
3, okay
So wie der das macht, könnte man das danach wieder zusammenbauen und es funktioniert noch
Guck mal hier, sogar ein Stoßdämpfer
Telefonstoßdämpfer, ja
Ob das noch einen Klinkeanstecker hat?
Okay, spätestens jetzt würde ich das nicht mehr zusammenkriegen
Ich muss sagen, das macht einen relativ stabilen Eindruck, was sie hier konstruiert haben
Das macht einen recht soliden Eindruck
Ja, exzellent Stoßdämpfer
Er hätte es jetzt noch in den Finger stechen müssen, dann wäre das Video Monka Toss gewesen und YouTube hätte es gesperrt
Also wie gesagt, ich hätte es wahrscheinlich nicht zusammen bekommen wieder
So, das war's für heute.
Das macht einen guten Eindruck, rein vom Guck macht das einen ganz hochwertigen Eindruck, das Teil auf dieser Slider-Mechanismus
Gerade als Tafel, also ich finde das an sich nicht sonderlich sinnvoll das Ding, aber ein cooler Mechanismus ist es
Sorry, Kappa vergessen, man weiß nie beim Chat, die haben ja auch ein paar Leute, die haben zu viel Geld
Und anstatt einfach jetzt mir 30 Subs zu giften, kaufen die sich so ein Telefon
Das ist ein interessantes Ding, wirklich die große Daseinsberechtigung sehe ich jetzt nicht mit diesem Geklippe und Swifle-Swing-Winge
Aber warum nicht, coole Sache ist es
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt mal als nächstes an, was haben wir hier? Ah ja, Hardware-Home-Server-Setup
Ich lasse da immer gern über die Hardware, die andere Leute haben, exzellent, das machen wir jetzt mal kurz
Oh guck mal da, die gleiche USB wie ich, sieht zumindest fast so aus
Du hast aber ein kurzes Video zum Ketten, ja dann schick mal
Was ist das?
Ein Cycle
Was ist nicht alles für das Rockspace, habe ich noch nie gehört, Rackspace, gerne
Langweilig, weiter, ich will die Kisten sehen
Schublade, guck mal das ist ja sogar richtig ordentlich Schublade im Rack
Man könnte natürlich einfach auch einen Schrank verwenden, ja
Aber warum nicht, wenn eine Schublade drin ist, kann man sie auch benutzen
Warum hat man einen Server zu Hause, ja weil man vielleicht Sachen drauf laufen lassen will
Ok, weiter, weiter
Was ist das, ein KVM-Switch?
Ok, das ist ein Netgear-Switch, das ist ein KVM
Was ist das, da hätte er auch gleich das Ikea-Rack bauen können
Wozu hat er da eine Holzlatte drin
Ah, das ist eine Konsole, ah jetzt verstehe ich, jetzt verstehe ich
Aber wozu, ich meine die Konsole kann man doch normalerweise auch so ins Rack bauen
Verstehe ich, verstehe ich nicht so ganz
Die haben irgendwie alle eine Konsole im Rack, die Dinger sind übelst teuer
Klar man kriegt auf Ebay, also wenn schon wird man die auf Ebay gebraucht kaufen, da kostet sie nicht so viel
Aber der Sinn von einer Konsole im Rack ist gerade im Heimbereich, finde ich fragwürdig
Ja, also
Wenn mein Monitor kaputt geht, ich schließe da gar kein Monitor an
Ich schließe aktuell, wenn ich mal wirklich da hinten in das Rack rein muss
Es ist cool, das stimmt Maxis, schließe ich meine Capture-Card an
Was meinst du mit Konsole, das hier
Das hier, das ist ja kein Laptop im eigentlichen Sinn
Das ist quasi ein Monitor und eine Tastatur, die an den Server dran gehen hinten
Und das ist halt eingebaut im Rack
Ja, man kriegt die relativ günstig auf Ebay, aber ich finde es im Heimbereich nicht so sinnvoll
Es gibt andere Sachen, entweder ich mache es mir, ich schließe einfach euer Capture-Card ran mit einem 5 Meter HDMI-Kabel reich dicke
Oder aber kauft euch für 50 Euro so ein KVM-Ding über Netzwerk
Das ist eigentlich das beste, was man machen kann
Sich so ein IP-KVM-Ding kaufen bei Ebay zum Beispiel
Wenn man wirklich das Problem hat, dass man öfters mal Remote dran muss, kauft man sich so ein Ding
Das ist übrigens viel zu teuer, das gibt es deutlich billiger, das gibt es teilweise irgendwie 30, 40 Euro
Kauft man sich so ein Ding und Netzwerkkabel rein, Server angeschlossen und gut ist
Finde ich für den Heimbereich praktischer
Wieso braucht man das, was gibt es, das nicht geht per SSH?
Zum Beispiel ins BIOS
Wenn du ins BIOS willst, kannst du das nicht über SSH machen
Wenn du ein Betriebssystem installieren willst, da im Installer rumklicken willst, kannst du das meistens auch nicht über SSH machen
Sollte der Server mal nicht booten und kein SSH selber starten, kannst du auch über SSH nichts machen
Ansonsten machst du alles über SSH
Genau, weil das brauchst du nämlich auch noch im Zusammenhang mit so einer Konsole im Rack
Wo gibt sie für 50 Euro? Ich habe mir so einen gekauft und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich da K110 Euro ausgegeben habe für
Ich habe so einen Teil hier
Oder alle deine Server haben ein Management Interface, das geht natürlich auch
Und ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass ich da kein 110 Euro für ausgegeben habe
Der Kram kostet teilweise übel
Da kommen wir schon eher in die Sache
Hier 40 Euro
So etwas da in der Richtung
Hier ist es natürlich ein bisschen teuer
So etwas da in der Richtung geht auch, wenn man sowas braucht
Oder wie gesagt, die Boards haben wirklich ein Management Interface, das kann natürlich auch sein
Aber die meisten Sachen im Heimbereich haben kein Management Interface
Es sei denn, man kauft sich fertige Server
Na doch, gibt es was günstigeres
Sogar auf Ebay kosten 100 Euro aktuell
Wenn man sich natürlich fertige Server kauft
Irgendwelche Dell Geschichten oder alte Gebrauchte auch noch
Dann haben die alle ein Management Interface
Aber die meisten Leute haben im Heimbereich eher kein Management Interface an ihren Kästen
Aber cool ist es, nice ist es, so etwas im Rack zu haben
Ob es was bringt, ist fragwürdig, aber nice ist es
Doch, ich habe ziemlich genau dieses Ding hier
Das sieht fast original so aus
Das was wir gerade eben bei Ebay haben, sowas hier in der Richtung
Ebay fast original aus, wie das Ding was ich mir mal gekauft habe vor zwei Jahren
Hier Ebay
Ja, sowas da
Ziemlich sicher, dass ich, das sieht sehr sehr ähnlich aus zu dem was ich habe
Das habe ich mir wie gesagt vor drei Jahren oder so, schon zwei drei Jahren mal gekauft
Aber ich bin mir auch ziemlich sicher, dass ich das nicht für 100 Euro gekauft habe
Sondern dass es ein bisschen billiger war
Ich kann es mich aber nicht einigen, aber selbst wenn man 100 Euro nimmt
Ist das immer noch billiger und besser als einen KVM-Switch und eine Konsole sich zu holen
Neue Copypasta, ja
Ok, das ist jetzt nicht so spannend
Ja, gut
Wie gesagt, ihr wisst, dass ich Mikrotik-Fan bin was Switches angeht
Wenn würde ich mir da, wenn ich sowas Neues bauen würde, würde ich mir da irgendeine Mikrotik-Switch hinhängen
Wahrscheinlich den kleinen mit zwei 10G-Ports und 24 Gigabit-Ports
Ja, alter die Copypasta, jetzt geht es los
Die Copypasta, alter
Die ist so richtig dumm
Ja, das ist ein alter
Obwohl, ist das so alt, zeig mal her
So alt ist das gar nicht
Das ist auch ein selbst zusammengewurstetes Gehäuse, das doch nichts fertig ist
Dann hast du den Server bei dir stehen
Dann hast du den Server bei dir stehen und hast ihn erstmal hibernated
Ok, das ist langweilig
Was will er meinen?
Ok, das ist ein bisschen was neueres, das ist nur so 3 Jahre alt
Aber eins muss man eh mal zur Gute halten, was ich bei dem cool finde
Der hat den Kram selbst gebaut, der hat sich keine fertig gebrauchten Dells oder so gekauft oder HPs oder Lenovo's
Das ist was selbstgestricktes hier
Das wäre cool, wenn er mal aufmacht und die Platten zeigt
Ah ne
Ok, da ist mit Hotswap schonmal nichts
Wenn, wenn du von, ne das ist natürlich doof
Also ich mein, wenn ich schon so nen Setup hab, dann will ich Hotswap haben mit den Platten und nicht, dass ich das dann ausbauen muss
Was ist hibernate? Das heißt auf deutsch glaube ich Ruhe, Ruhe, Zustand oder so unter Windows
Standby
Ok, aber ne NAS, also ne NAS ohne Hotswap
Gerade wenn man hier die Möglichkeit hat, wenn man hier großes Gehäuse hat und passendes Rack und so
Ist eigentlich blöd, wenn man das ohne Hotswap macht
Das ist die gleiche USB, nice
Also das ist die gleiche USB, die ich auch habe, die mittlerweile ja kaputt ist
Eine USB ist ja kaputt
Jetzt ist auch so ein Ding, ne? Ich hab mir eine USB gekauft, dass ich es, dass ich ausfallsichere bin
Und was ist das erste in meinem Rack, was kaputt geht? Die USB
Na logisch, ne?
Also, Sebaro, jetzt gucken wir uns das Video vom Sebaro an
Oh, oh, was, Moment, was mach ich hier auf gerade Sebaro?
Was sie mögen
Zwar handelt es sich um einen der größten jemals entdeckten Nebel
Benannt wurde er jedoch
Ach, Moment, was, ich hab's, ich hab's
Sie mögen Sternebel, dieser ist besonders atemberaubend
Bestaunt werden können sie allerdings viel
Zwar handelt es sich um einen der größten jemals entdeckten Nebel
Benannt wurde er jedoch nach etwas zartem und kleinem
Gachi, was?
Ja
Ja, warum nicht?
Ist doch, ähm
Gibt's so viele Nebel?
Irgendwann gehen einem die Begriffe aus für
Ne, Microsoft ist halt der Meinung
Dass dir Rosette, dass dir der Rosette Nebel gefällt
Ist halt die Frage, haben sie damit richtig gelegen?
Ja, mir gefällt mir, sonst kriegste demnächst noch mehr
Exzellent
So, ähm
Gucken wir ihn jetzt
Dann bin ich denn schon on
Was, 3 Stunden 17 sind schon an, ich krieg nämlich langsam Hunger
Advanced useless machine
Exzellent
Was?
Exquisite, das brauch ich
What the fuck
Hahaha
Ja super
So
Ja, warum nicht?
Warum nicht?
Ja
Vor was es nicht alles Videos gibt
Ich mein, es ist bestimmt ein cooles Projekt, das selbst zu bauen
Da lernt man was, da sind Motoren drin
Motoren ansteuern ist nicht
Also diese Servos ansteuern ist nicht so ohne
Ja
Exquisite
Was ist Arduino Pro?
Ich glaub das sind die neuen, kleinen
Ich glaub das sind die kleinen
Die es seit 2 Jahren oder so gibt
Hier diese kleinen
Ja
Die gibt es doch nicht so lange, die gibt es erst seit
2 Jahren oder so
Aber finde ich lohnen sich immer noch nicht wirklich
Wenn man einen ESP32 nehmen kann
Warum soll ich einen Arduino Pro nehmen
Mit äh
Mit einer 16 Megahertz CPU
Wenn ich billiger
Einen ESP32 kriege mit
Dual Core
240 Megahertz CPU
Gut, vielleicht mögen die
Arduino's ein bisschen robuster sein
Meine Facecam ist dead
Oh ne, ich schalte gleich wieder ein
Ok, da kann ich
Da muss ich jetzt gleich wieder flamen, weil es wahrscheinlich
Sachen sind, die ich nicht machen würde
Ok, also das haben wir uns alles angeguckt hier
How does Microsoft make money?
Can this really avoid objects?
Das interessiert mich tatsächlich auch
By the way, wo wir gerade wieder beim Thema sind
Ich hab hier den Vorgänger von dem hier
Ich hab den Roborock S50
Oder S5, das ist der gleiche
Und den hab ich geflasht mit
Custom-Firmware
Sodass ich jetzt ein Webinterface habe
Von meinem Staubsaugeroboter
Wo ich mir zum Beispiel die Karte von meinem Wohnzimmer ansehen kann
Und dann seh ich, wo ihr das letzte Mal gefahren ist
Im Wohnzimmer
Guck dir, da ist die, das stimmt übrigens nicht
Die Station ist da und da steht er
Minecraft auf dem Staubsauger geht nicht, weil die
Aber nicht ordentlich läuft
Wenn man letztens wieder im Wohnzimmer rumgefahren ist
Wui, wui, wui
Dahinten ist der Sessel, da kommt er nicht ran
Ja
Liegt, Wohnzimmer, liegt
Ja, und das ist der Grund, warum ich
Die meisten Sachen in Custom-Firmware flasche
Das ist die Sache, weil
Ich werde ja immer gefragt zu Max
Warum, wozu sollte man
Ein Staubsauger flaschen? Ganz einfach
Dass ich in den Webinterface
Nein, das hast du mit der Original-Software nicht
Mit der Original-Software hast du
Die offizielle App, mit der das geht
Nicht über den Browser
Und auch schon mal gar nicht ansteuern
Ordentlich über deine Heimautomatisierung
Ohne China-Cloud
Äh, ich hab das hier drauf
Das da
Das hab ich auch im Staubsauger drauf
Die haben auch Pre-Build
Firmware hier irgendwo
Ja, übrigens, das ist der Grund
Ich hab irgendwie
Kein Bedürfnis, einen Staubsauger-Roboter
Mit Kameras zu haben
Und wenn überhaupt, dann
Mit Custom-Firmware
Ich hab keinen Bock, dass irgendwelche
Eine Wohnung-Film
Also, meiner hat oben drauf nur dieses Radar
Das ist kein Radar, das ist so ein Laser
Der die Umgebung scannt
Oh, AI
Onboard Reactive AI
Ich würde mal sagen, sonderlich viel AI
Ist da gar nicht dabei
Das ist ganz normales
Äh, analysieren von irgendeinem
Kamera-Feed, ich glaube nicht, dass da
Sonderlich viel Machine-Learning-
Gedöns abgeht auf diesem
Staubsauger
Nothing is sent to the
Ja, deswegen brauchst du ja auch
Einen China-Account
Cloud, China-Cloud-Account
Dass diese Dinger überhaupt
Einrichtbar sind
Ich glaube noch nicht mal, dass das
Eine großartig Machine-Learning-trainierte
Objekterkennung ist, ich glaube das ist was ziemlich
Rudimentäres
Auf der anderen Seite
Auf der anderen Seite kann schon sein
Mittlerweile sind die Sachen da ziemlich einfach zu benutzen
Wir machen das übrigens auch demnächst im Stream
Mit YOLO probieren wir das mal aus
Warum?
Warum hat er in jedem seiner Videos
einen Kackhaufen von seinem
Hund drinne?
Das ist doch gar kein echter
Kackhaufen, oder? Das ist doch irgendein Spielzeug-Kackhaufen
Fake-Kackhaufen ist das
Pet-Waste
61%
Der macht doch YOLO-Erkennung
Das ist übrigens genau das
Was wir demnächst auch mal probieren
Mit YOLO-Objekt-Detection
Und wenn Object-Detection
Sogar einen Scheißhaufen erkennen kann
Zu 61%
Zum Glück gibt es das Emoji, ja
Leute, das wichtigste Emoji was kaum
verwendet wird ist
Das da und das da
Beides Sachen, die sehe ich total selten
Aber sind oft angebracht
Besten Emojis
Und wer mittlerweile auch von fast allen Betriebssystemen
Und Emoji-Fonts
Und Emoji-Renderer und Font-Renderer
Und was dann nicht alles braucht unterstützt
Wer ist der Kotz Emojis?
Äh
Ist klar, ist klar, ist klar
Der China-Anbieter sagt Hij nimmt Privacy Serious
Jaa natürlich
Nein, niemals, niemals
Niemals würden die chinesen was in die cloud packen. Nein, NIEMALS!
Also, du kannst nichts auf die Kameras sehen,
bis du es zuerst aktivierst.
Dies enthält Bilder von den Objekten, die es zuerst zu entdecken
und ein Live-View des Kamera-Feeds,
bei dem du alle drei Knöpfe auf dem Vakuum halten musst, um zu aktivieren.
Das Live-Kamera-View ist toll, aber...
Oh, das ist cool!
Dass man mit dem Kamerading rumdüsen kann in der Wohnung ist cool, das hat was.
Es war so viel Spaß, mit diesem Feature zu spielen.
Everything was so responsive and it basically became a big toy for my family.
This is actually a useful feature as well.
Da kann ich, da könnte ich meine Katze stalken mit.
Da merkt ihr nicht, dass ich anrücke.
Da kommt dann der Roboter angefahren und guckt, wo sie steckt.
Remember when I mentioned the vacuum got stuck from too many obstacles?
I loaded up the Live-Kamera-Feed and drove it out with no problem.
You could also use it to check on things in the house if you're on vacation.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob's custom firmware dafür gibt.
Roborock S6.
Gibt's dafür schon Custom-Firmware?
Oh!
Gibt's anscheinend schon Anleitung zum Hack des Roborock S6?
Aha, aha.
Aha.
Okay, was muss man dazu machen?
Was ist das?
Alter.
Okay, was muss er, was muss man dazu machen?
Äh, weil äh, endlich ist es möglich.
Also, okay.
Oh fuck, man muss das Ding zerlegen.
Oh shit.
Okay, das mach ich nicht.
Ach du Scheiße.
Okay, ganz so sehr übertreiben wollte ich es jetzt eigentlich nicht, dass ich das Teil
auseinanderbauen muss.
Ach du Kacke.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, man muss das wirklich komplett zerlegen.
Äh, kritisch.
Kritischer Hase.
Paints-Champ.
Okay, man muss das Ding wirklich komplett auseinanderbauen, sodass man wahrscheinlich
an die Pins von der CPU kommt oder so.
Ach du Scheiße, nee, nee, nee, das krieg ich im Leben nicht, doch, doch.
Ich würd's wahrscheinlich schon wieder zusammen, aber ehrlich hab ich kein Bock, das ist ja
eine, das ist, da brauchst du ja zwei Tag für.
Du musst alles genau fotografieren und machen und tun.
Das ist nur Part One.
Ach du Scheiße, der baut das Ding ja wirklich komplett auseinander.
Ah, ah, ah, okay, das sind jetzt, das sind die, okay, okay, jetzt hab ich's verstanden.
Also, was das ist, ist, das ist die serielle, das ist die serielle Schnittstelle, die hat
dann mit einem Kabel verbunden, dass er sie von außen verwenden kann, man könnte vielleicht
ordentliche Kabel nehmen, dass sie keine Kurzschlüsse verursacht, aber okay.
Hier ist also der serielle Port dran.
Ach du Kacke, ah, Moment, das sind isolierte Kabel, ne, das sieht nur so aus, als wär's
Kupfer.
Ja, das sind die, das ist die serielle Schnittstelle hier, okay, Part Zwei, wo ist Part Zwei?
Ach du Kacke, das mach ich nicht, das mach ich, guck mal, das krieg ich im Leben nicht
wieder ordnungsgemäß zusammen, dass es funktioniert.
Da warte ich lieber noch ab, bis man das Ding ordentlich routen kann.
Okay, Tools Required, schrauben Sie sich mal, habe ich, habe ich, das ist so ein Adapter
über USB auf seriell, quasi, die, die Dinger braucht man auch, wenn man andere Microcontroller
flashen will über USB, das, da hab ich ein paar, da hab ich ein paar verschiedene von,
das passt, hab ich auch alles, also ich hätte theoretisch alles da, was, den S5 Max muss
man auch zerlegen, oh, das ist fail, ich konnte meinen über den Raspberry Pi noch flashen.
Okay, das haben wir alles, das haben wir alles, okay, okay, ich will, okay, das ist, okay,
das ist irgendein, was auch immer, hatte ich noch nie was mit zu tun mit den, das ist
ein STM32, okay, das ist ganz gut, STM32, die, hä, ach, der hat zwei Sachen drauf,
wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Real-time Sachen, den da und sonst eine normale ARM CPU für
den Rest.
Ubuntu 14.04, wobei, wir wissen ja alle, dass die korrekte Aussprache Jubantu ist,
okay, wo geht's los, ach du kacke, das erscheint mir äußerst kompliziert zu sein, ja, okay,
ja, also das muss er ja machen, um zu gucken, ob der Download stimmt, danach guckt er, ob
das ordentlich signiert ist, dass das nur Firmware vom Hersteller ist, warum soll der
Staubsauger denn geroutet werden, weil geroutete Staubsauger besser sind als ungeroutete Staubsauger,
weil es geht, ach ja, und weil man ein Webinterface bekommt und nicht mehr die China Cloud braucht,
also es hat schon seine Vorteile, das verstehe ich auch nicht genau, warum so viele Firmen
was gegen root haben, die einzige Erklärung, die ich habe davon ist, dass sie ein bisschen
Bedenken haben, dass sie halt nicht dir quasi aufzwingen können, was sie wollen, also sprich,
zum Beispiel, wenn die jetzt der Meinung sind, die nächste Appversion braucht ein Abo, dann
können sie das machen, was sie nicht machen können, wenn da eine Kiste geroutet ist, wobei
man sagen muss, die meisten China Hersteller, die sind gar nicht so scharf darauf, das Routen
zu verhindern, gerade diese ganzen Tuya Steckdosen, was es gibt, da ist der Hersteller nicht so
scharf drauf, das Routen zu verhindern, weil ich glaube, ein ganz großer Teil der Sachen,
die da verkauft werden, sind, weil man sie routen kann, wer keinen Bock auf Routen hat,
sind die Zwischenhändler, die sich diese Geräte kaufen, ihre eigenes Logo drauf machen, obwohl
sie da nichts selbst produziert haben und die verkaufen, die haben da keinen Bock drauf,
der eigentliche Hersteller bei diesen ganzen Smart Steckdosen und so was, die haben da
wahrscheinlich gar kein Problem mit, deswegen kommen bei der ganzen Tuya Hardware, die sind
ja auch immer so schleppend, was Sicherheitslücken fixen angeht, wo man routen kann, die haben
da selbst gar kein großes Interesse dran, die machen das nur, wenn die Hersteller ihnen
aufs Dach steigen.
Bei mir sind alle Geräte geroutet, bei mir auch mehr oder weniger alles und dann sind
wir noch in einem custom isolierten WLAN.
Ja ok, wie das funktioniert, weiß ich, das glaube ich jetzt auch verinnert, so wahnsinn
interessant.
Das ist normales Firmware-Update, wie du das machst, das funktioniert auch, die andere
Variante ist nicht, dass der sich das Download der Roboter, sondern dass du es aktiv drauf
pusht und du hast halt zwei Systempartitionen, eine aktive und dort, wo das OTA drauf gemacht
wird, also das Over-The-Air-Update und dann switchst du um, wenn das OTA erfolgreich
war.
Ich hab Hunger, ich muss gleich was essen.
Welchen Mikrotik-Router kannst du empfehlen für unter 100€?
Müsste ich gleich mal gucken, aber der klingt sinnvoll, für unter 100€, für ein bisschen
mehr kriegst du aber schon, wenn es ein Router sein muss, dann nicht, aber für ein bisschen
mehr kriegst du schon den Switch mit zwei 10G-Ports.
Aber das ist dann nur ein Switch, ne, das ist dann auch nur mit SwitchOS, du kriegst den
CSS32, hier guck mal, den kriegst du schon für 140$, das ist aber nur ein Switch, du
kannst da kein Routing-Gedöns mit machen, das ist wirklich ausnahmsweise nur ein stinknormaler
Switch und du hast zwei 10G-Ports und 24 oder wie viel auch immer das sind, was ist das
hier, 8, 24 1G-Ports, das gleiche gibt es auch noch in der Variante, wo du Router-OS
drauf hast und Layer-3-Funktionen benutzen kannst, obwohl man halt sagen muss, die CPU
da drauf ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig schnell und auch nicht für Routing-Sachen ausgelegt.
Aber wenn es unter 100€ sein soll, gibt es da gar nicht so viele Möglichkeiten ehrlich
gesagt, mit vielen Ports, was hast du vorgeschlagen, den CRS125, Moment, der ist aber nicht unter
100€, also wenn du den kriegst für 80€ spricht da nichts dagegen, du hast aber kein
Gigabit, also kein 10G, der ist auch schon ein bisschen älter, aber was hat denn der
für eine CPU, ja der hat eine ordentliche CPU, damit kannst du auch ein bisschen Routing-Firewall-Gedöns
machen, wenn du was brauchst für ein paar Kleins, die CPU ist ganz in Ordnung dafür.
PoE kann er auch, wieso, kein Unify kann man auch machen, ging jetzt aber explizit um
Mikrotext-Sachen.
Ich mag die Unify Access Points von den Unify Switch, ich habe einen Unify 10G-Switch muss
ich dazu sagen, aber einen Edge-Switch mit Web-Interface von den normalen Unify-Dingern,
ich bin jetzt auch kein riesen Fan von dieser Unify-Oberfläche, für WLAN-Sachen ist es
gut, aber für einen normalen Switch oder einen normalen Router will ich einen Web-Interface
oder einen Kommando-Zahlen-Interface haben, wo ich den konfigurieren kann und gut ist.
So, schauen wir mal.
Okay, zeig mal wie geflasht wird, how to root, disassembly of the device, haben wir
schon mal gemacht, connect, serielle Ports, aha, ah, jetzt wissen wir auch warum der Typ
da Kabel dran gelötet hat, das braucht man um das Root-Passwort aus dem Bootloader raus
zu bekommen.
Und anscheinend hat der Hersteller gelernt, der Hersteller hat nicht mehr ein Root-Passwort
für alle Geräte, sondern nur Custom-Root-Passwörter pro Gerät.
Das ist ja fies.
Beim Roborock S5 war es noch Root-Passwort für alle Geräte gleich, oder Flash-Passwort
oder wie auch immer man das nennt.
Okay, zeig her, also phase one, disassembly machen wir gerade, ach du große Kacke, das
den krieg ich nie wieder zusammengebaut.
Das ist serielle Schnittstelle, dranlöten, ach du kacke, so, dann wird sich seriell drauf
connectet um den Bootloader abzugreifen, genau, jetzt kann man das Root-Passwort da drüber
wahrscheinlich abgreifen, was ist das, ah man muss ne Batterie dran machen, dass das
Ding Strom hat, okay verstehe, Strom über USB geht anscheinend, das ist krass kompliziert,
wenn das nicht einfacher wird, ne, oh hier ist das, okay hier ist der Bootloader, hier
ist вс côté der Bootloader, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy.
Ich habe die Fluchtkontrolle in deinem Terminal eröffnet.
Hier ist eine kurze Demonstration der Verbindung.
Zuerst verbinden wir die Batterie.
Ich habe die USB-Kabel zu den Füßen und zwei Schrauben.
Ich habe sie bereits gesoldert, aber hier möchte ich zeigen, wie sie aussehen, wenn sie gesoldert werden.
Ich bin gespannt.
Abenteuerlich! Abenteuerlich!
Echt abenteuerlich!
Jetzt musst du diese zwei Demonstrationen typen.
Du kannst sie kopieren und pasten aus dem Dokument in der Beschreibung.
Der erste Demonstration ist, dass du den Objusketet-Root-Passwort in die Erinnerung ladest.
Der zweite Demonstration ist, dass du den Bereich der Erinnerung lernst.
Wenn du eine zweite Person hast, die die Schrauben hältst, kannst du...
Okay, das ist das Root-Passwort.
Ach du Scheiße, was ein Ack!
Scheiße!
Also, wisst ihr was?
Mir juckt es ja in den Fingern, das auszuprobieren, aber einfach nur...
Was kostet das Ding?
Aber einfach nur so viel Geld ausgeben, weil man mal wieder ein bisschen basteln will, ist glaube ich ziemlich sinnlos.
Guck mal, wie alter!
Ich gebe doch keine vier...
Ne, Moment!
Kek...
Kek-Wait!
Übrigens ist viel zu teuer, das Zeug.
Ich habe für meinen 290 Euro bezahlt von RoboS50.
Ah ja, okay, das sind Preise, da lasse ich mir schon eher gefallen.
Die Preise lasse ich mir schon eher gefallen.
Also, sagen wir mal so.
Sagen wir mal 390 Euro.
Oh, das ist...
Moment, das ist ein anderer.
Das Ding heißt nur S6.
Das ist hier G-Bait.
Ah, egal, gucken wir mal weiter.
Nur der Max hat die Kameras?
Wie ernsthaft?
Also, 400 Euro muss ich ausgeben, okay?
400 Euro muss ich ausgeben.
Aber das mache ich nicht.
Nein, nein, nein, das lohnt sich nicht.
Also, das sehe ich nicht ein.
Ne, ne, ne.
Das sehe ich nicht ein.
Einfach nur zum Basteln gebe ich 400 Euro aus.
Das ist wirklich komplizierter als ein iPhone zu jailbreaken, ja.
Das ist Big Brain.
Ein richtiges Big Brain erfordert das.
Ich baue mal kurz ein bisschen Musik im Hintergrund an.
In diesem Schritt brauchen wir UART wieder.
Also, wenn du es vorher verbunden hast, dann musst du es wieder verbinden.
Wir müssen den Ubuntu Linux booten.
Und das kann durch diesen geprinteten Befehl gemacht werden.
Oder durch das Repowering des PCBs.
Sobald das Device in den Linux gebooten ist, siehst du den Prompter für den Login.
Du musst die Musik wieder ausbauen und den vorherigen Befehl...
Meine Güte!
Wenn der Login erfolgreich ist, nimmst du die IP-Tabels minus F.
Das wird alle Firewallen ausbauen und wird SSH genießen.
Wenn du die Kabel hältst, kannst du sie jetzt ausbauen.
Denn die restlichen Schritte können über SSH gedreht werden.
Wenn du eine stabile UART-Konnektion hast, kannst du sie wirklich ausbauen.
Das ist wirklich nur für Hardcore-Leute.
Das Wichtigste ist, dass die Veränderung des Firewalls nicht permanent ist.
Also starte dein Device nicht mehr.
Hier ist ein anderes Demo.
Das ist so was, das wird nie alt. Das mag der Chat immer.
Richtige Hacker-Mens hier.
Minecraft auf dem Staubsauger? Java läuft nicht richtig.
Auf, VM, geh mal an.
SSH, root, add... Moment, was?
Oh, was war das?
Das ist ein Staubsauger-Fünne.
Wenn man es richtig schreibt, root, add, yes.
Was war das Standard-Passport?
Cleaner? Ich glaube Cleaner.
Ha, bam, hier. Leaked, OMG, leaked wieder.
Also bringt euch eh nix.
Wir stellen fest, wir haben vier CPU-Kerne auf meinem Staubsauger.
Also das bringt euch wirklich nix.
Ich weiß, dass jetzt mit den Leuten das klippen werden und sagen, oh mein Gott, da hat irgendwas geleakt.
Bringt euch absolut gar nichts, was da steht.
Es sei denn, ihr wollt meinen Staubsauger flashen.
Da müsst ihr aber erst mal hierher kommen und euch an den Staubsauger arbeiten.
Also wir haben vier CPU-Kerne.
Und zwar ARMv7, vier Kern, CPU.
Wir haben sogar einen Hardtop auf dem Staubsauger.
Das ist doch mal was, oder?
Ja, und warum ich mich eingeloggt hab, ist...
Okay, da ist tatsächlich ein unbunter 14.04 drauf.
Dann war es umgedreht, dann war es vorher sogar ein 12.04 und jetzt ein 14.04.
Die Chinesen sind da ein bisschen hinten dran.
Ich dachte nämlich eigentlich, es war am Anfang ein 14.04 und jetzt ein 16.04.
Aber ist es gar nicht, es war am Anfang ein 12.04 sogar.
Die sind nicht so aktuell, was das angeht.
Aber das ist wirklich hardcore kompliziert.
Ich will mal gucken, woran die Firmware flasht.
Ich will sehen, woran die Firmware flasht.
Hier, Custom Firmware.
Sogar das Firmware-Update ist übelst komplex.
Okay, hier muss ich die Firmware runterladen, dann irgendwie Gedöns ankreuzen, Firmware downloaden.
Dann rüber zu SCP, mich einloggen auf dem Roboter.
Dann irgendwas patchen und dann installieren.
Boah, fuck, Alter.
So, jetzt zeige ich das nochmal.
Das ist, der ist auch deutsch, der Channel ist Dennis irgendwas hier.
Dennis Giesel.
So, Firmware rüber kopieren.
Dennis Bigbrain, ja.
Aber richtig Bigbrain.
Exquisite.
Der hat bestimmt lange noch hier Chat mitgekocht, dass er so Bigbrain geworden ist.
So, jetzt wird das Ganze entpackt, okay.
Boah, ist das kompliziert.
Fuck, das mache ich nicht.
Easy.
Man muss nur drei Tage an dem Staubsäure-Roboter rumschrauben.
Das ist tatsächlich cool.
Wenn man viele Geräte hat, dann hilft das was.
Okay, es ist extrem kompliziert.
Und ich glaube, es gibt auch noch nichts Neues.
Das ist schon von Juli.
Vielleicht gibt es da jetzt was Neues zu.
Wir gucken mal hier Past Month.
Nee.
Aber das ist schon echt heftig kompliziert gewesen.
Wie sind wir denn überhaupt da drauf gekommen?
Hier, als der Dude da mit rumgefahren ist.
Jetzt erschreckt er wieder sein Hund.
Der Hund guckt schon immer so panisch.
Würde mich bei dem Herrchen auch nicht wundern.
Der erschreckt fast in jedem Video sein Hund mit irgendwas.
Da kommt der Roboter reingefahren ins Wohnzimmer oder irgendwo und guckt, wer da ist und sagt permanent
Kamera aktiv.
Das ist ja auch nervig.
Also das Video mit dem Firma Flaschen hat mich echt fertig gemacht.
Also ich sage euch mal jetzt, wie sagt man, meiner kann auch wischen.
Dieses Wischfeature ist ja also wirklich Dreck kriegst du damit nicht weg.
Das ist, das ist schön, wenn man, dass man ein bisschen mehr oberflächliche Sachen vielleicht mitnimmt.
Das ist, das ist brau.
Ja, das ist, es ist vorhanden.
Ja, aber sonderlich toll funktioniert es nicht.
Hast du den auch auf Wisch bestellt?
Paints Chip.
Cute Joke.
Max Suction.
Also, da liegt aber noch Zeug.
Guck mal, da liegt noch Zeug.
Das ist nicht alles weg.
Guck mal da, da liegt immer noch Zeug da.
Der muss schon noch ein paar mal drüber putzen.
Ja, das hat meiner auch, das ist sehr praktisch.
Im Wohnzimmer liegt ein Teppich, da hörst du immer, wenn der auf den Teppich fährt.
Sonst pumpt er normal vor sich hin.
Und wenn er auf den Staubsau, wenn er auf den Teppich geht, macht er dann.
Und dann denkst du, oh fuck ist jetzt und dann fällt dir ein A, er ist auf dem Teppich.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Gut, das kann ich mit meinem auch machen über das Webinterface.
Ja, und das ist jetzt auch ein neues Feature, das hatten sie übrigens vor der offiziellen App,
dass du den quasi über verschiedene Stockwerke verwenden kannst.
Also du kannst den quasi dann die Treppe runter tragen, wenn du putzen lassen willst.
Weil ansonsten hat er nämlich immer die Karte vergessen.
Aber doof, dass man nicht flaschen kann, also nicht ordentlich flaschen kann,
weil man ganz im Ernst das Ding aufschrauben und dann irgendwelche Sachen da ran.
Das ist mir ein bisschen zu kompliziert.
Das ist sogar mir zu kompliziert, weil ich Schiss habe, dass ich das Ding,
dass ich dann 400 Euro zerstört habe, weil es nicht mehr funktioniert.
So Leute, ich habe übelst Hunger. Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream. Guck mal, wir haben fast alle Videos geguckt heute.
Das Einzige, was wir nicht geguckt haben, ist das, das ist nicht so wild.
Das haben wir auch geguckt. Das ist auch nicht so wild und wie Microsoft ihr Geld verdient.
Excellent. Also sagen wir hier. Bookmark all tabs. Neuer Ordner vom 1.11.
Excellent. So, ich war mich vom Arka. Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Bis dahin macht es gut. CU.